greetings from podcast Ville that you're
the Church of what's happening now is
right I [ __ ] started there something
I believe that the Church of what what's
happened now is brought to you by
23andme 23andme is DNA testing service
that can offer insights into your
ancestry your health your wellness and
different traits the 23andme health and
ancestry service includes reports on how
your DNA can influence your weight your
sleep quality you cafe knit the caffeine
intake sense of taste whether you're
likely to be lactose intolerant and a
lot of other stuff it's easy to do - you
just spit into a tube you provided into
23andme kit and you mail your saliva
sample back to the lab to be analyzed
what I'm gonna do is this order your
23andme health and ancestry kid at
23andme dot-com slash Church that's
23andme comm slash Church the church is
also brought to you by my boogie [ __ ]
if you had khabib in the over oh [ __ ]
but listen that's over watching football
is fun but it's more entertaining when
you got a little action on the game
alright I can't watch no game if I don't
[ __ ] bet it so guys you heard me talk
about this for weeks and there's still
some E on the sidelines my bookie
is the way to go all right you know why
cuz you win and they pay login to my
bookie right now and double your money
use promo code Church and you'll get the
first deposit match at a hundred percent
that means if you put five hundred up
you get five hundred from them again go
to my bookie right now and at the promo
code Church you play you win you get
paid
take this [ __ ] melee people walk -
ladies and gentlemen the flying Jew and
you uncle [ __ ] Joey on the Tuesday
morning what else may be messy man love
yes you do good to be here it's great to
[ __ ] have you we didn't get you
stoned tonight so there's no
misunderstanding yeah I'm all good yeah
I got the [ __ ] weed the [ __ ]
Cavanaugh [ __ ] enough before you choke
that [ __ ] that
because nobody talked about weed that's
what happened well I like your tweet
where you said ask ask her if he had a
big dick you know yeah what the [ __ ] you
see this big time we have what's color
the [ __ ] scab is yeah I'm saying
remember you ever see that movie Porky's
yeah
Porky's one of the great I know Lee
didn't see he was too busy watching
orange is the new purple control is
getting [ __ ] in the locker room only
ones alive yet but the chick from Sex in
the City is getting [ __ ] in the locker
room and this shows these girls taking a
shower and the shows like their tits and
they're all washing themselves and
there's a hole in the wall and a guy put
his dick in the hole in the wall it's
[ __ ] hilarious you know you're a kid
you laugh it had to be it came out like
I'm 84 and the next scene is the chick
the chubby [ __ ] lesbian gym teacher
with the principal and the guy and
they're going so what do you want us to
do and she's like I want you to put an
end to this somebody has to find this
penis and he goes what do you wanna do
do us get a sign and put have you seen
his penis you never saw that move I saw
that Sporty's penis scene it is [ __ ]
legendary because they're how I let this
woman into her face it was just like
what happened to Senate committee
hearings they were just laughing at it
like she's like you know I want to get
to the bottom of this I want to I want
to find this dick but she kept want a
penis and they like so what do you want
us to do find the deck put Porky's penis
in for dick scene whatever whatever
works can they show [ __ ] penis on
YouTube maybe not look there's
tallywacker scene yes yes that's the
what tallywacker she kept calling them
tallywacker no and he's like so what do
you want us to do this is one of the
greatest [ __ ] scenes yeah right there
Porky's tallywacker
let's see if they [ __ ] even show
I know this is completely on ourselves
but I think this is the only way just
live in space and he's trying to tell
the kid not the lab look seduce and
destroy there must be stuff she's
extremely dangerous
[Music]
look at the gym teacher and the other
guy a [ __ ] Talon grab the guy's dick
in the showers Oh No look at the
principal space he's died the last look
at the other two dudes like George Jones
up there
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
have you seen this break that's comedy
guys right there he's [ __ ] dying
inside and that kid won't stop torture
them that's the video you guys got to
see Porky's to tally at the scene then
they focus on this is the [ __ ] real
director this is as stupid as this movie
was I remember I'm yeah memory so I'm
gonna watch him for the tents there was
like this always came on like an 11 and
11:30 in 1984 like cuz they did
something they did something they showed
you tits and the chick from Sex in the
City every time she [ __ ] she would
yell out she would moan laughs uh-huh so
the old lady on Sex in the City
her well she was in this movie Porky's
[ __ ] man movies that came out at the
same time the one before this was called
Hollywood nights in fact I'm doing
something for the guy Mike whatever he's
in that movie he's directing something
for the comedy store like a showtime
documentary Mike binder his name is he
had a show on HBO called mind of a
married man huh he was newbomb Turks
buddy in that movie Hollywood nights
which they pretty much cast out of a
Comedy Store in 1982
that's how long Mike behind has been
around so close to what are you shooting
for them like a documentary about the
movie about The Comedy Store about how
many a five-hour a five-hour documentary
thing of interview comic started there
before well where's it gonna come out do
you know
no [ __ ] idea with the question I'm
asking the question to be there they do
a contract I go down there I talk for it
now when I get the [ __ ] out of there I
don't give a [ __ ] how the [ __ ] are you
you're on tour with Kid Rock Tour tour
and got a new album coming out I'm doing
these West I'm gonna I'm bum you're not
doing these West Coast dates with me man
ya know cuz I cancelled on Portland last
year because I had your problems so
that's the date I'm important
yeah it's a bummer I wish I mean I'm
gonna miss you on those it'll be fun
uncle are you here for the LA show can
you and Lee come out again I don't know
what like the LA show is you have to
tell me I don't know maybe it's at the
Novo downtown I want to say in November
2009 I leave our Thursday Thursday
Friday Saturday
I think it's 3rd I think it is 3rd trust
me we'll [ __ ] that weekend you know
bro every weekend I'm out is the weekend
with something Goods happening like this
weekend I was home for Conor McGregor
and whatever but usually I'm on the road
right I just got invited to see Skynyrd
in Nashville I'm really out of time for
that but me out yeah it's always
something people have no idea where your
schedule can sister they have no idea I
would love to go see Judas Priest and
[ __ ] uh and whatever they were
talking white Mike whatever was talking
about today on the radio how different
is the Judas Priest opens up for smoking
on the water whatever the [ __ ] that band
is we did smoke on the water you don't
remember now Jesus smoke on the law uh
I'm I'm blanking man she said you didn't
even smoke reefer you're the [ __ ]
deep purple deep purple a syringe so
they were talking about the comparisons
about deep purple why Deep Purple's
closing the tour that you people are
gonna see Judas Priest and leaving so
where's this they're doing something I
think the LA County away something I
don't know what the [ __ ] at this I think
I think could have happened already but
I was like when people invite me to [ __ ]
you know there's one week that I have
three days in town so I have to
accomplish everything I do in five days
yeah that's the thing people don't
understand is these long weekends these
won't kill you but two long weekends
y'all sudden everyone's like oh you only
have to work weekends to long weekends
you're in town two days you know and it
used to be a longer
for Kombi when I got into comedy it was
Tuesday through Sunday yeah it's like my
[ __ ] oh I've got an answer by Saturday
you don't want to even [ __ ] crack a
joke I mean I'm actually happy that
we're even when I do have to do
Wednesday through Sunday or something I
mean we used to do we used to go out to
28 days in a row so I'm actually happy
where we are now you know looking back
at all that [ __ ] like I love all that
stuff I could there was a time when I
could do that I mean when I was a kid
there was 5050 tour what's that guy
telling been condemned abandoned he does
like a rockabilly type music he's been
around since I was a [ __ ] kid that
guy hmm I can't [ __ ] Oh deadly no no
he's a white dude George Turner George
sterile good hands Troy is George
sterile good one year in 82 maybe 81 to
the 50 50 50 states and 50 [ __ ] days
I'll [ __ ] you do that matter [ __ ] you do
that bad well I don't know how I mean
are you I'm at the age now where I don't
know how the [ __ ] I did this year I did
last year like how'd I get through those
shows I don't even know no you love
something enough like you'd love it but
then you have to look at your time yeah
and what goes with that time you know
it's just too much time away from home
you know okay you don't have a kid no I
have a son now don't ya I didn't know
that's what my new records about
congratulation ww3 does it he's six
months yes you know how it is
yeah man I can't keep but I gotta say as
he gets older you don't want to be no
matter how famous you get you don't want
to be that type of dad yeah I mean I
feel but I don't want to be on the VIP
but I don't want to be at a Kid Rock I
mean nothing is kid Rock I don't want
playing Kid Rock shows my kids growing
up no but even if you go out on your own
no matter what you know and you do you
have to keep the lights on
yeah but right now it's how it pays the
bills but yeah I know what you're saying
like I every weekend's of is its yeah
you know look at these older rock stars
now yeah they go out but they play every
other night they're on testosterone you
know they're doing they well I know I
know they're their bodies you can't
drink it can you imagine you a drinker
and snorting a fire you know I know dude
- I mean I don't know him but you know
there's the big guys now they do private
planes yeah every show yeah yeah and I
think I don't want to say Kid Rock goes
to every
beep flies into a lot of [ __ ] I think he
does at least we'll have him drive no I
think he flies in to the shows I don't
want to speak for him but that seems
like them like the thing that would make
it a thousand times easier if you didn't
have to wake up early you could just get
on the plane
no security yeah you don't have to make
thing you don't have to go through
airports you know but like yeah the big
I heard you know a lot of the big bands
some of the like the biggest bands they
walk back show ends they walk backstage
get on a plane there they sleep in their
bed every night we have a friend chemo
does security for slash and you know
whenever he comes to town
from Guns and Roses he always calls [ __ ]
I wish I'd seen that reunion
you're invited whatever this weird I've
had conversations with him Denise had
done this last kind of roses tour he
didn't see Axl Rose tell Mike the second
or third month that they fly
independently oh I believe he in my life
that money is just so insane they just
get there on their own they check into
it you see him on stage y'all you see
him what stage dish their high five
nobody's getting high no more nobody's
drinking everybody goes back to her
[ __ ] room and plays the guitar and
takes a xanax and goes to sleep and they
get up little see each other why don't
you know you're at a certain level I
mean I wish I could do what I was doing
in my 30s now I wish I could leave on
Wednesday and come back on Sunday and
take three planes in between now it's
like that Pennzoil commercial you either
gonna pay me now or you haven't paid me
later cuz it drags with you even if you
get off the plane do a little workout
drink water get a good night's sleep
well this trip for me not to interrupt
is like you know it's just a couple I
have to come here for a couple days of
meetings then I fly back to Nashville
and two hours after I get back I get on
the bus because I get up drive overnight
to Atlanta to play that night which is
fun I mean you listen it's the life I
chose but it's still a bit much I need
more than two hours you watch steven
tyler i'm steven perry steven tyler and
Rogin yeah yeah did you see his [ __ ]
schedule at 68 no it's crazy yeah I mean
it's crazy
I actually watched some of his Netflix
special which wasn't that great but it
was it was him trying to do country you
know but it was you
I was kind of just it was puffs you know
it wasn't that great but yapping Steven
Tyler was in the 58 years old he was
talking about his schedule you said
they'd go holy [ __ ] I thought I had it
tough this guy is on the move and he
writes everything down he was I mean he
still seemed pretty I mean he did a lot
of drugs be seen worth it to me yeah all
those guys listen that was just a period
in their time whoever that guy's essence
when you watch him on rogue and that day
is essence came through like no guest
Rogan ever had you could tell that
Johnny Depp's full of [ __ ] and you see
this guy he's the original Johnny Depp
oh yeah I mean my favorite music guess
he's had recently that I thought James
Hetfield from Metallica was awesome
James Hatfield was great like go to guys
you don't see him talk like that no but
Steven Tyler took me to it like when he
started talking about uh-huh
to check that from Beaumont Texas that
Oh deeds you know what there was three
people old deed morrison [ __ ] Hendrix
in the chick what was the name chance
shop Janis Joplin I said I went to see
Janis Joplin and haja and listen if you
listen to the early albums those yells a
Janis Joplin oh yeah I never thought
about that you want to welcome Lee's fly
he finally got here diamond you pet fly
he's got a pet fly got a pen man you can
go year without seen this is service fly
yes he has a certificate if you [ __ ]
what competizione missile is ohms neck
he's like [ __ ] it that's that dude that
loses a plan Apple is because I'm
worried Joe is gonna come in my house
one day and find hummus I know you eat
it no I don't mean homeless up my fridge
trust me you eat hummus every day that's
why you dragged great which is great
debate he said hummus wait wait til
[ __ ] Isis comes over at this point
I'll give Isis your address but they're
not coming on with my house because only
numbers there they go where the hummus
is no the people who like a mic but
anyway like can you explain to people
because I mean I had a regular job but
we the most recent of us three okay so
there's people who work forty hours a
week and like oh I'd love to just sit on
the plane and then sit on the hotel and
then go do that well I get it it's more
tiring than it sounds like just your say
I'm eeen here's the thing here's where
you I know what you're saying and I
agree 100% I used to be a kid
watching the people on TV complain about
their schedule I would get so [ __ ]
pissed at them I go I would give my
[ __ ] nut left not to have that life
but it's just you know and I'm not
complaining I love it but it's just I'm
not my mom miss Kay I love what I do I
know and I love not having time for
stupidity no that's good nothing I love
more than how I got all the stupidity
out of my life but like you were talking
about before the show mean there's the
people the lazy [ __ ] who just who
wanted to just take shortcuts ain't no
[ __ ] choice there's no shortcuts and
then and you see it over the years that
people keep attacking them and you see
the people that keep attacking shortcuts
and after a while you stay away from
them because that's all they are is the
[ __ ] shortcut you know I'm not
complaining at all about my schedule I
love that you know what pisses me off
what's that wasted time yeah exactly
no I got time I wasted over the years
that's what pisses me off today what
well everybody in this room that's what
I try to tell you people with this
[ __ ] stupid podcast as stupid as this
thing is I'm 55 I go on the road a nice
family whatever but there was a lot of
wasted time there was 20 years of wasted
time that I was 28 my garbage garbage
watching be on my drugs and drugs the
movie watching the sports that there
were so many things that didn't matter
that you don't know - you're 55 yeah but
I think the drugs and alcohol is what
doesn't I mean you don't sit around when
you're motivated and sober watching
movies all day you know a limitation
I've always been a motivated guy when I
was 16 my mother died and when I was 20
I realized that you're alone in this
world so get that out of the way right
there I was always a hustler
wheeler-dealer I was always up to
something but I could sit there for 10
hours and watch movies
12 hours I can watch off a Charles
Bronson festival by myself it was okay I
learned a few things I got into a
business so it wasn't a waste of time
it's research but you know that's why
when I see young kids and they tell me
they don't hold for a sport day like I'm
sitting here watching knowing I'm a
I don't get it because once you really
get into life and what you find what you
love that [ __ ] don't matter I love that
[ __ ] me yeah I mean I I think nothing
but the only thing that can it can get
in the way of your private life I think
when you get too obsessed with it don't
you think well I always think of wood I
always think of woman if I was a woman
and I dated a guy and if he broke my
balls on Sunday then he had to go sit
with other guys at a bar to watch a game
that guy would be dumped my guy would
dunk that [ __ ] guy as a woman you
know any guy that's above [ __ ] thirty
that comes to me and says as a woman
that he has to play softball with his
buddies he's got yeah he's history like
I don't believe I've never believed in a
lot of stuff I don't believe in watching
cartoons after a certain age and they'll
watch the same sense I don't watch [ __ ]
I don't give a [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ]
you watch cartoons when you're a [ __ ]
kid you want to put a Superman on when
you sure darling you're 25 go choke
yourself you know I'm doing nothing for
yourself you know I'm saying like I
always I already knew that
like at 26 and 27 like I had to stop
watching football like I remember
sitting in a bar and with my friends
watching football going what the [ __ ] is
happening in my life
there's gotta be something I could be
doing than sitting here waiting for a
drug delivery and watching football but
I was homeless at the time and I had no
choice
yeah but I couldn't I couldn't I
couldn't wait to get out of hanging out
in bars I couldn't wait I know I'm 84 I
could I was 21 and I didn't want to walk
into another bar ever again like I was
contempt at 21 not to walk into a bar I
never really did I'm kind of the same
way it's like you know sometimes I'll be
on the bus Sunday driving back from the
Saturday night gig it's like an all-day
bus right and your your instincts
sometimes to complain about it but then
you think like I worked my [ __ ] ass
off for this and it's a nice [ __ ] bus
you know it's not a big you know what's
up what the [ __ ] do I need we'll need to
be at home doing the same [ __ ] [ __ ]
well my favorite videos of Walt
his bon jovi better a lot because they
show him on the bus after a show wiping
his face and I remember being a civilian
like selling cars I'm watching that
video my dick getting art because I was
saying that's a life on the road is like
having being on Greyhound buses going
Bon Jovi did it you know way that like
yeah yeah well that's the thing too is
you know what to me the great equalizer
of tour buses are you know there's not a
bus in the world week that you're can
take your [ __ ] on you guys know that
right you cannot trade on I'm going on
the tour bus why can't get you on the
tour bus because where the [ __ ] is it
gonna go you can't dump it on the
[ __ ] highway
you can't [ __ ] keep it in that thing
and the whole bus is gonna smell like
[ __ ] so it doesn't matter how [ __ ]
rich you are
ain't no [ __ ] on the tour bus so you
can be [ __ ] Aerosmith you can be
[ __ ] wheel Walker jr. no matter what
you got like a row of code amongst
musicians yes you don't mean really but
it so I gotta [ __ ] this [ __ ] at 4:00 in
the morning cuz I lived in an RV for a
while like take tight ginormous shits in
there in the RV [ __ ] ya then once a week
you take it to some places
oh no no yep got it gets $1 now puts the
holes on the [ __ ] ain't no but you
weren't living with five [ __ ] people
I was living with a girl with RV and
it's not like [ __ ]
no it's not like [ __ ] tropical
paradise yes but wait yeah exactly
well I mean I'm so on the bus I don't
want someone else to know that's how I
feel that's when people asked me today
do you wanna go on a tour bus I go first
off I don't want to smell another man's
feet
I already did time yeah when you do time
you smell men's feet and then you smell
men's [ __ ] you just smell in the air
cuz people don't want to take showers I
can't live with that
you know that's my thing now just like
all your whole life my whole life now is
revolved well how the [ __ ] and where the
[ __ ] I'm gonna take a [ __ ] but like I
said it's worth it I would aren't tour
bus is really expensive they can't bus
you just I'm just saying there's eight
guys on the tour bus if I got a stop
every time somebody needs to take this
[ __ ] we're never gonna get nowhere
no no they ain't no you guys look it up
ain't no tour bus you can [ __ ] on some
ups I think they're some really chop it
up I'm not kidding and like listen
Ralphie may have a tour bus if anybody
has [ __ ] there was that [ __ ]
yeah won't bought what's-his-name's old
tour bus together plays largest I was
their foot up on stage Matthew I just
done so we just we rent tour bus every
weekend we just had Axl Rose's old tour
bus no [ __ ] on that is there is
there is there a toilet it's the toilet
yeah yes yeah listen imitation I could
never be in a band because I [ __ ] four
or five times a day especially with
coffee so if I got to pull over after
the third time I'm [ __ ] that
bathroom when you flush it and you light
incense and you come out I don't want to
smell nobody else's [ __ ] I never do
that's why I don't go to the bathroom at
the airport you were walking to the
bathroom at the airport in five in the
morning it's like a tornado of 18
different shits going on there's not
even that you those can't even handle it
the many I mean I'm with you but I were
there it's [ __ ] horrible but when you
gotta go yeah I'm with you man I
shouldn't some [ __ ] crazy places this
past year place I never thought I would
even I don't know how I did it but when
you gotta go that [ __ ] bad I was one
of those kids that used to hold on to
stuff and I got sick and then I made it
a habit just to [ __ ] when I had this
[ __ ] and it started you know like that
Freddie Prinze killed himself 19
whatever I was walking home it was
[ __ ] freezing and we used to cut
through the cemetery we'd see devil
worshipers through there doing [ __ ] they
chase us and [ __ ] and one night I had a
[ __ ] night went in there and I'll never
forget taking that [ __ ] looking back and
the guy had been buried like an 1891 I'm
like nobody visits this guy you know the
saintly visitors guy a guy nobody left
this part of New Jersey like not
bragging where we cut through the
projects was old it was old and I
remember that was the first time I took
a [ __ ] outside
I like pissing in my pants I didn't take
my pants all the way off oh [ __ ] I [ __ ]
my cat peeing and when I put my pants on
and they were frozen it was so cold
outside that my pants got like icicles
on and I had to walk home like the 10th
man [ __ ] was there like I can I like
ice hanging from your day it was ice on
my pants like it froze that fast but I
pulled my pants off like well he's hot
too oh yeah there was steam coming out
and stuff but it was that cold that it
was mid-january in Jersey I knew there
was a reason why I remember
Dave Matthews tour bus do you remember
in 2004 his bus driver was on a bridge
and dumped 800 pounds of poop off the
bridge but a river cruise was going by
at the same time in the book you'll see
well I'm saying but yeah that's exactly
right he he was the guy who tried to do
it he can't do I mean you don't fit in
the [ __ ] ocean but there's people who
will [ __ ] stick holes in the Darvey
or the tour bus and they suck all this
[ __ ] on top of you okay well I gotta
find this guy altogether yeah there's
there everywhere all those places where
you stop on the road with trucks there's
always a creepy looking guy back there
you know I think it is I think is maybe
it's my book
I think maybe it's a personal thing I
think it's $1,000 five if you fight me
to your home I will I will not take a
shitty yeah really I have a rule I won't
take a [ __ ] of your house you don't take
a [ __ ] I'm not playing hey I have a rule
there's only one person who broke and
then had to pull them aside what imma
have a little talk that was re came to
my house I [ __ ] attached that Jews you
can't do that to me understand me oh
it's not like [ __ ] Jew Ville wouldn't
you say to him how to pull them aside no
listen there's an unspoken rule don't
[ __ ] in my house and I won't come to
make me go to your house and take a
little [ __ ] there's a little ship in
three days and knock on your door and
I'll [ __ ] destroy that bathroom oh
like an animal so there's a rule amongst
Joey beers I gotta go to your house once
you start smelling the first two farts
if it's me and if it's appreciate I'm
out of your house how about this but
anyone listen that's my name rules I'm
taking that Robbie with [ __ ] in hotels
like during the weekend what I [ __ ]
lightly like only little like 6h pieces
come on they're like little nuclear
waste but when I get home on Sunday with
that uber driver drops me at home I take
the key out of the suitcase I go in the
house I'm I drag the suitcase all the
way to the bedroom I take my computer my
notebook out and whatever weed I brought
home from the weekend I put in the
office right away before I do anything I
going that back to back bathroom then I
will come a piece of 40 to 48 inches of
the whole weekend [ __ ] because my
[ __ ]
is a [ __ ] decent person he doesn't
even like [ __ ] people well how do you
know how do you not do it all we get at
the hotel us my stomach knows I'm fun
that's crazy yeah you all right you I've
been doing and this is not good for me
it's before like an eight hour drive and
I know I can't [ __ ] on the bus I'll sit
down the toilet and try to push
something out which I think that's bad
for your [ __ ] [ __ ] whoa that's how
Elvis died what you need to do is smoke
a pipe while you're doing it
so when you coffee push at the same time
that's a trick gospel Joe you don't even
go out I'll [ __ ] do I do it in the
morning I'll drink coffee I feel like a
little something but nights not ready
yeah but I guess what's the night what's
the pipe - the pipe makes you coffee the
weed so when you do a bong hit you cough
right so when you caught when you coffee
look your [ __ ] opens up kua right now
yeah so by a tiny go so if Elvis had
coughing they don't need me alive I
don't know if I was sort of cobble I'm
just telling you this burgers with
peanut butter and this how Joey Diaz
does you got a friend named No unless it
man I'll try it
I don't like pushing either I believe
that's how you get a heart attack that's
how Gigi died at the Sopranos yeah
that's how I always died someone told me
that people find people down like cops
that's the most common place to find
people dead when they like people look
neighbors are complaining this apartment
stinks so busted finally a guy sitting
on the toilet I hope I don't die on the
toilet yeah I hope I don't die taking
like a mule [ __ ] they gonna take me off
and dirty ass turns me well don't you
know don't you [ __ ] when you die don't
you - [ __ ] you have one last fart left
at you I'll never forget when my mom
died I picked up alarm and share one
last fart left of it and it came out of
ass it's not like a skunk died and
[ __ ] stomach I swear to god I'm not
trying to be cute yeah well my mom died
before the ambulance got that I was
trying to revive her
what was it happen you that [ __ ] was a
heart attack but you always have that
last gassing that's why they do stuff
during that the autopsy but the the when
they prep you for the funeral yeah they
do something so that last fart won't
come out of you because it's horrible
well you just stick I don't know they do
something they do something I don't know
you know I hung out with a guy that did
that as a living
all my years of them like the mortuary
mortuary business I me and him got down
we talked about everything but it was
like on it's unethical to talk about
what you do different not the autopsy
but the other procedure will they do the
embalming yeah well a bunny mom didn't
break your spines they break your spine
so you don't pop up huh what
yeah because you have you have those
muscles still left in your body like in
Cuba when you die didn't have no
embalming fluid they just put you in a
living room and a [ __ ] homemade
casket and they buried you when you
started stinking so my mother would tell
me you go to these [ __ ] places and
all of a sudden okay that would just pop
up and you got a break is back to get
him down like sometimes in harm comes up
why why is it come up because it's no
more to say it's the last tensions of
your muscle so you're honorable like
they always say don't hit your mother if
you hate your mother your hand will pop
up and they have to break it to bury you
like I heard my buddy told me one time
then when he was a kid I did pop up and
they pretty much had a [ __ ] break it
huh buddy of mine was doing that it has
that job he was telling me years ago he
was doing it to some dude and the dude
and you you see the dude naked obviously
when you're doing it he said dude had
[ __ ] me tattooed on the head of his dick
oh my god that's always great that's not
something you want to see yeah the guy
was [ __ ] you all his dick yeah but
then that that's that tattoos gotta hurt
that's gotta be one of the worst jobs
the world is finding death yeah that's a
horrible place to put your mind after a
while you know it's gotta get to you you
have to pick up bodies all day like I
used to pick up bodies with him
sometimes like you know he was my buddy
like that he was to help me like he
would go what he don't know let's take a
right and we've got a Kennedy Airport
[ __ ] smoke a number and pick up a
body off a plane like when they're
taking the luggage out there let's go
all the way back there and I feel lucky
to get tossed off with the bodies come
off so his people who were raised in my
area but had moved to Florida to retire
and they died and they flying back I
can't tell you how many runs we made
well I go pick up a body with him the
freaky out yes and no yes and no to a
degree I learned how to deal with it but
I'm not supposed to be around that stuff
I couldn't be around that stuff
constantly it's a when I go to wakes
it's terrible yeah I try not to I don't
like I don't know this [ __ ] I don't I
can't do it no more than anyone yeah
last week I opened up a Facebook page
and one of my dearest friends had a post
it said a life changed forever that her
mother died and I just broke down at the
[ __ ] computer because I know what she
was feeling like I called her up I said
flowers you know and so that's the least
I could do but at this age I can't go to
a wake I can't walk on the way there's
no [ __ ] way it brings back too many
[ __ ] I went to 20 weights my first
[ __ ] 25 years of life I'm done with
mics I went to another place just like
I'm done I'll go to a cemetery in fact I
don't even after the last the last thing
I went I started a fish [ __ ]
like that's how I'll speak what I mean
that's how emotional I get the last
Laurel I went to that's why I didn't go
to MIT seashores because I know what a
[ __ ] got into a fight why do you get
in fights as I just get confused it
brings me back to being a kid and as
they say a good funeral there's always
gonna be a fight yeah I mean no a
funeral then my mother died so there
were like hands like five days is just
confusion because they were Cuban people
and the Cuban funeral parlor where they
had my mother was open 24 hours in his
Jersey Jersey it was West New York New
Jersey Rivero funeral parlor that's
still there but a different owner this
guy was friends with my father in Cuba
and he he came to me after I had already
booked my mother in the funeral appalled
he came through and he goes you can't do
that he goes how are your father a favor
let me have her in the funeral it was
[ __ ] four day wait 24 hours so me my
uncle and my mother's best friend how to
cover shifts you know and you didn't how
old were you 16
yeah as to you never stay and I had a
friend that died in the 8th grade
and in a year after my mother another
buddy from the eighth coming that same
class that blew two doors down from me
died so I went the three heartbreaking
wakes and then in highschool girl got
old car accident you know all those
little [ __ ] wakes and one that was I
can ain't gonna waste no more because it
takes me out of the game for three days
it brings me back to me being there at
that [ __ ] wait for four days you know
that's gotta be a tough time for a
family but you gotta go deal with it
like I remember having they gonna and
identify my mother and then my aunt's
like where's the earrings the [ __ ]
internet stole the EMTs stole her
diamond earrings he's you know and then
there was drama this and I'm my aunt was
like a spicy Cuban woman she wanted to
talk to the EMT and smacked the [ __ ] out
of them then they're gonna we had to
switch funerals and then there was drama
with my stepfather and then they put the
wrong dress on my mother so the lady
choked the funeral director during the
[ __ ] wake dog you heard are annoying
yeah and then [ __ ] during the wake
I'm gonna forget this there was a scene
during my mother's wake we were in the
[ __ ] like in the parlor and people
bringing bottles of booze and my people
are bringing bottles of booze to bury my
mother with the pinch that's what she
drank bench and the whole it was like
people I'm gonna lose my license you
can't if I can bring booze in the end
thank you even thing
yeah like you bury them with whatever
coke [ __ ] Cuban saying which whatever
and I'm gonna forget that Rivero
the funeral director was in the hallway
telling like my aunt my you know what
the rules were like he can't have booze
here and before he get the words out one
of my mother's friends I thought oh that
was a bookie when in his pocket took out
I don't know how much it was like
hundreds he just put it all the sudden
you can happen if the guy's pocket if
the guy was like I can't take your money
he goes I don't give a [ __ ] and the two
doors opened and our Nardo's brother and
one of his buddies was carrying not like
a regular cooler but one of those long
coolers filled with beers and they just
walked past
I remember sitting there going and they
stopped and asking where were they gonna
put the beers and the guys like you
can't have beer at a Funeral Parlor lose
my license they didn't give a [ __ ] and
then they started drinking and they
start playing dominoes then they started
snorting seriously Oh
once they would start snorting I'd have
to leave these Cubans are crazy and
you're 16 or 16 is this every Cuban part
no but they take that there's some
Cubans who go back to the old school and
they take a 24 hour wait for two or
three days and it's 24 hours that means
when that that after wheel Walker gets
off stage in LA and has his 15 drinks in
this 20 bumps you can go stop by and pay
respects so you show up with a bottle of
the grandma blow and they would I get
there at 8 than 1 maybe 20 people that
snorting and drinking around my mother
and [ __ ] like that trickles away before
what's the meaning of that tradition I
don't understand just it's a party it
didn't want it to be sad it's not racy
that that I kind of liked again it's a
celebration and they don't want it to be
like a [ __ ] I'm just thinking about
being 16 I don't know that I would want
a party you know I didn't want a [ __ ]
party I just wanted to bury this poor
woman she had gone through hell and all
said they were just laying all these
things on me the window a church
ceremony and I just was just I was like
do whatever the [ __ ] you want
she smoked exhaustion trying to figure
out what the [ __ ] I would do with my
life and you [ __ ] absolutely
stupid questions like what color shoes I
don't [ __ ] know I'm saying like I
just didn't want to hear it I was just
numb for five days was just a lot of
interaction you have a lot of people you
haven't seen people talk to you people
pull your side you know I was those
wakes it's just a [ __ ] nightmare that
I don't wish anybody to go through that
stuff like when people call Mia over the
last 10 years I've had a couple of my
friends call me and go hey man for a
couple years I didn't like here but I
lost a parent and I see what I'm going
through and now I understand you a lot
better huh I can't imagine being 16 and
going through what I'm going through at
40 I can't imagine I just got ahold I
can't I can't
yes it was terrible it was terrible it
was terrible when I think about it I
write about it it comes out black and
white like that part of my life you
think there was like some way not to get
to deeper like some trauma there that
you were dealing with ever since then
absolutely I think that's what the drugs
came from ah
I was already that's what's that bless
that blame the [ __ ] drugs you know
saying everybody blames drugs on
something I was already on my way
all right I'm about being in the
hospital and they scraped my lung and I
wasn't doing blow that but I was
snorting angel dust I was at THC crystal
THC we didn't scrape you're on I had a
lung infection no higher a quat from
them spraying chemicals aren't weed to
kill it and the dealer's was still
selling it so a bunch of people got sick
mm-hmm I would spit blood pure blood I
had a lung infection and what what they
couldn't figure out what it was so they
were like I'm gonna scrape you along I
stole them just the sound that doesn't
sound yes what they do is they state
they put you out and they put a tube
down your throat and they take a sample
of your lung a little piece of your lung
and they put in a micro [ __ ] scope
and they see what's going on you don't
want to time you wake up you coughed a
little bit there's a tube dying and what
it say what doesn't say that he does
anything I just said I had some type of
infection but I was scared and the
doctor was gonna say in front of my
mother did you do [ __ ] angel dust so
I was already out so how what age was
that 16 15 okay by 12 I was already
smoking dope see is I was not doing and
I enjoyed it
in fact every time I hear Bohemian
Rhapsody I giggle my ass off because I
still remember smoking a joint between
like eight of us and go on a blimp II
base on my 33rd in Union City and that
song was on and when he was on Mamma Mia
Mamma Mia
we [ __ ] lost it we just lost it
giggling the management had to come over
and throw us out yeah that'll type of
[ __ ] and then we were just more I was an
athlete so I didn't want it to get out
so I would just smoke with the downtown
crew the crew from my neighborhood we
would smoke already loved weight at 12 I
didn't hide it from my mother I had
- but you're saying you started pretty
yet well not heavy once a week I was
like a [ __ ] ceremony on Friday you
knew you liked it oh we would have a
blast how can you not like giggling for
five [ __ ] hours when you're 12
giggling uncontrollably giggling then
[ __ ] eating and then having to put
Visine in your eyes and Binaca and
[ __ ] have to walk is he a mate when I
was a little kid and I didn't smoke weed
I always got paranoid II didn't like no
I loved it I liked it better than
alcohol I'll pay that I didn't like the
feeling out all alcohol always gave me
this trap feeling marijuana gave me this
other feeling and I discovered marijuana
music well yeah well that's the thing
when I got down to that was it by the
one was 14 I was done once once the
first time you smoked weed and put on
those headphones a change I can change
Alaia yeah you know I was telling leader
I'd what Dark Side of the Moon on vinyl
a couple weeks ago when I came in here
one night it's at the house was 9:30
everybody was in bed like oh man just
sit here like the mo Clemente school
gets a man did I came to your office and
I must have done less six bonnets and I
put that Dark Side of the Moon it took
me back and I still remember gold with
this kid named Vinnie Lynch it'll look
just like Mick Jagger god bless us all
he just died about four years ago he
took me to like a reservoir and we took
like a hit acid we drank like we split
like a six back up and again I must have
been freshman year in high school and I
went home with an acid started [ __ ]
hit me we were walking hard and I still
remember laying in bed listening to the
other side of Dark Side of the Moon it's
like money in that [ __ ] money with the
computer and boy I started tripping I
had julius erving poster I had a
McDonald's all-american team poster on
my wall but the posters I had that was
the weirdest
there was a Led Zeppelin picture that
was going around but it was backwards so
they said that poster be a collector's
item they only made like 200 of them
it's probably [ __ ] there's probably
a thousand but there's a Led Zeppelin
poster from the 70s it's backwards
job Bob who's playing the different
wagering left-handed you know
everybody's different because it was
it's [ __ ] crazy and that poster
started talking to me and [ __ ] and I
closed my eyes I prayed to God like so
you know I woke up the next morning cuz
I'd puked
I'd puke all over my shirt and I had a
piece of gum that I had in my mouth
stuck on my shoulder from the gum from
the guitar took mushrooms once and I
swear to God that I had a Nirvana poster
I swear Kurt Cobain was talking to me
and I stole in this to this day I can
picture it in my head I can picture him
his mouth moving from the poster and you
know I still held out for Coke I did the
THC crystal but the drug I was hooked on
the most was microdot acid that was the
one that was from 15 to about 16 and a
half I was on a [ __ ] 17 I was on a
tear with mica that acid I had I would
give one hit two people out by for
ninety cents of piece and selling for $3
I would go to East Stroudsburg
Pennsylvania and pick him up on the
weekend so far that I don't know that
area like two two and a half hours from
where I live and I just saw the kid on
Facebook they used to drive me after all
these years he just popped up on
Facebook and I haven't even afraid of
him yet there's Facebook [ __ ] up man
does sometimes it brings up good
memories sometimes man okay this kid was
a great kid yes kid had no reason to
even take me there he liked me he
trusted me it was two years older than I
was he had a driver's license I didn't
and I would buy [ __ ] from him and it was
overwhelming and one day he just said
well if you just [ __ ] sell it
yourself did you kill him it
I was killed killed you know I knew how
to get rid of and my school people would
show up and play hooky and take acid and
then they'd go buy beers and go to
Hudson County Park and they tripped his
[ __ ] like that every dad had ten girls
playing hooky I had these little group
of hippie chicks dirty white chicks and
I would sell it mescaline every [ __ ]
day were you making decent money off I
was making two 2005-2010 cents of it and
I was selling three four hundred hits a
week plus I was selling black beauties
I was getting black you're making you're
making a full-time living doing that
full-time living working at a lumberyard
Robin with three hands from the
lumberyard you understand me I mean
Robin in blind in the lumber yard and at
the same time said I would get these
black beauties that would make you go
crazy with diet pills but heavy-duty
diet pills that's why they call them
white beauties I would get $1,000 for 35
hours but the wrestlers that had a make
weight I would sell them a hundred for
35 hours the profit was unbelievable
that's how much I sold one for at our
union dollar and I'd sell a hundred a
day of dollars so as soon as I got a
thousand I had four or five wrestlers
that would buy a hundred for me so that
covered my 35 and I'd make like $100 and
then the rest was a dollar apiece twelve
to ten dollars I would [ __ ] sell
those things I was getting those for 35
cents okay hey what man you write you've
changed turn your life around huh I knew
how to hustle I knew at an early age you
think that hustling I helped you in
comedy [ __ ] yeah
and help this type of hustle it's called
ingenuity it's called I didn't want to
work I had a central network of people I
could sell drugs to I didn't have to go
outside that boundary I don't have to go
on a little weight for a DEA agent to
pull me over when I picked up something
it was three quarters so I wouldn't pick
it up so I wouldn't lose any money so
another hot thing from he was quaaludes
quaaludes why hot Jack see you would pay
do you see what you see wall of Wall
Street yes I [ __ ] love that see yeah
I'm too old or too young I mean for all
Quentin's for the hottest drug out of
her from 78 77 to about 83 a [ __ ]
quaalude was top nine I never what it
how does it make you feel top that's
like 10 volumes and two shots of whiskey
just that [ __ ] show and girls and
they send girls know they call them legs
brothers girls know like I would pick
each
let's go for a ride what we doing - hell
no I was thinking let's split half a
quaintly and girls little my girls knew
what time it was and some girls would
fight it out and some girls would pass
the [ __ ] out but everybody knew what a
quaalude did that was a day with
moneymakers because on a Friday night
they went like that I'd pick up two
hundred quaaludes I'd pick up a hundred
Wailers for two hundred hours at four
o'clock and by six o'clock I'd be
cleaned up and make 200 bucks because I
told before at that agents on line I
would sell 200 on a Friday night and
keep cannibal for myself and me and my
friends would eat two or three I'd dump
my talent and then what happened was
people started making them at home so
you would have to look at it and see if
they spelt lemon wrong like some people
would smell lemon with two M's these
dumb [ __ ] so the two pharmaceutical
companies that made them were Aurora R o
R er and lemon which was le mo n those
are the four was in the fake ones they
weren't the faint ones were stronger
than the [ __ ] real ones because it
was just a young kid putting [ __ ] in a
[ __ ] thing but probably me was was it
good Shammi it's part that for you right
I ate a thousand real quaaludes and a
thousand bad quaaludes kinda like one
night with the quaalude I got real high
od'd with quaaludes at Joe Lucci's house
I'm Leslie Joe Lucci this weekend then
yeah I'm playing West Palm Beach I think
that he tells this and if he comes I'm
gonna tell the stories two guys is
supposed to come Loic a Stoli though I
like a towel an hour up stories of Louie
Louie Oh Louie knows that we saw some
[ __ ] growing up and that kid Joe Lucci
he would always have a pre-party for any
concert so any concept Madison Square
Garden you could kind of hangzhou Lucci
tapping I can't get four in the
afternoon she would go to his house
before get [ __ ] up till 7:00
jump on the train and go to Madison
Square Garden and when I spoke to him a
couple weeks ago we were talking about
Ted Nugent ac/dc and he goes I got you
beat December 6 1976 I was Monday Night
Football the Cleveland Browns beat
whatever he was I went to see
Ted Nugent open up for Sabbath [ __ ] man
that's how good his memory was that's
how good yeah I wish I saw Sabbath
reunion tour I wish I'd [ __ ] seen him
in the day let me tell you something man
I was you know got me hooked three
hooked on sabot Dean don't worry
Dean's a great dude these albums that
Sabbath put up over the last couple of
years they're not to [ __ ] cheb no
they're not bad they're not that shabby
they're [ __ ] still kicking ass for
[ __ ] whatever they are this Tony
Iommi I'm surprised I heard a song the
ident Ozzy's boneyard I had to run home
and put it on I was blown away
no I heard I saw him on like a tour a
few years ago but problem was he
couldn't sing he's 60 something I know
but they said he's had a goat singer for
years well that's what I told that's
what somebody said that there's someone
behind the stage singing for him that's
what I've heard
and I'm like well he took that [ __ ]
night off man he'll do that people have
go singers that's what the I mean Joe
and I heard the same story so it must be
true and lip-syncing okay you know
Britney Spears Jennifer Lopez Janet
Jackson
anybody who moves a lot when they start
a tour I bro and I know this because I
watch the university Colorado like took
the music horse and the guy who did
Janet Jackson's tour did a speech one
day and I went just went you know and he
was talking about when Janet Jackson her
tour starts 85 percent of the tour is
lipstick I'm not crazy because of her
cardio that the fourth Janet Jackson
will go on the road and 90s and early
2000s she would have to train for eight
weeks and even that wasn't enough
because you know we could dance like
then yeah you have the lights and this
and that and the adrenaline so she goes
it so in the beginning of the tour no
matter how much training you put in
eight weeks six weeks 12 weeks the first
you I know that the Ozzy story I heard
you know how he always pours bucket of
water over yeah so what I heard was
again I won't say who told me because I
don't know I won't give up my sources is
that he he pisses his pants onstage
cause he's so old and they kept trying
to figure out diapers and [ __ ] they
couldn't figure out what to put him in
say oh how about just dumped [ __ ]
water on your head
and then you'll be [ __ ] soaking wet
you piss your pants no one can [ __ ]
tell that's crazy that's what he does
that's what that's what I heard at least
when you were growing up when I was
growing up like if you look at a picture
Archie Bunker he was 46 years old he
looked like he was [ __ ] 90 oh yeah I
mean how old was Elvis when he died like
you you think about it now he was 42
someone was listening to blood on the
tracks the other day you know which is
when you think of old Bob Dylan he was
33 you know it's crazy
remember the Traveling Wilburys all
those old guys look up there ages man
it's crazy they're like all late 30s
except for the one guy had to be old Roy
Orbison yeah he was well I don't know
well maybe but Noah's or but not as long
as you think
no but he was already old you know
listen the longevity factor I did not
think I just saw a video Mick Jagger
rehearsing
did you see that video no but he still
he still 72 years old still [ __ ] one
heard they're making a new record yeah
yeah he don't give a [ __ ] you know him
he's money hungry as [ __ ] he's a genius
that guy but he's 72 and he's still
moving he's still having kids no you
don't give a [ __ ] he just knocks you up
Richards you can still [ __ ]
pyon-kichi I love ya I want to be with
you but this to do this I'll give you a
million dollars I'll see the kid once
again I'll come over and get a little
force cuz it's all over late you [ __ ]
I'm finally head over there that's what
he does all over the country he's 70 all
over the world all over the world
you think he's do you think he's taking
Viagra he's taking everything I know for
a fact he does testosterone really yeah
to go all those guys today I asked the
doctor one time
what was his biggest customers after his
music up actors of bodybuilders and he
knows my biggest customers are musicians
the musicians that you see today
that's how they keep going out and
working three nights you know Black
Sabbath they can't do it every night
they could do three shows in a week yeah
but that's it
what's the testosterone what's to do it
I mean it just keeps here I don't know
how it works I don't know how the
testosterone affects you it keeps you
movement it makes you
stronger you know I don't know exactly
what the components I'll tell you what
make Jack I mean looks like he's in
great [ __ ] shape you know Keith
Richards looks like a bust but I
guarantee you'll do a tour you still has
them to do it I saw a funny quote from
Willie Nelson the other day said
something about you know you kids gotta
take care of the planet cuz we need a
nut you know don't you know don't [ __ ]
up the planet cuz you got to leave it in
good shape for me and Keith Richards
how was Willie Nelson there I think 80
something he still going outside the
festival in Austin it's I think these
guys
I don't you just don't know how to I
mean Paul McCartney looks like a kid but
he's like he's [ __ ] old oh my god
Paul McCartney looks like a [ __ ] kid
he's torn right he was what's he what's
he's gotta be like he's gotta be almost
80 right Willie Nelson's 85 but what's
Formica 85 like would remember I mean
not he was pretty recently just living
to 85 was a big deal much less [ __ ]
Turin he's 76 who Paul McCartney yeah
Paul Paul was the young Beatle as well
70 [ __ ] and six
picture Willie Nelson 85 remember you're
my grandparents 85 no they come and I
still smoking dope Tommy's those oh yeah
yeah yeah but imagine he's lives on a
tour bus he tours at 80 [ __ ] five and
it's gotta be listen it's in your ate
when you're a musician especially I
think that the day you stopped playing
music is the day you die I think so too
well that's that's why I always say no
one retires I'll be really nice ya know
that [ __ ] well the people put on their
retirement tour then they come back out
like a week later like I can't imagine
not having a sense of humor after I
retired yeah like I need my sensor here
and then someone's gonna say you want to
do Friday night and then you'll do it
I'll be in an old folks home doing
Friday they're not ready I don't give a
[ __ ] making old ladies get dressed up
ask them about their monkey you know
he'll be an r-rated night with Uncle Joe
he's still 83 fall asleep on stage
wearing a wig yeah tell me I'll say I
want Joey open up my show and you'll say
can't do it he's 84 then I'll call you
myself
yeah I mean I have Lee with a
teleprompter
give me [ __ ] signs in the back cuz I
still put my [ __ ] boy when I'm
[ __ ] hate he is to be my dog
it'll be about [ __ ] that's what
that's my goal in music I want that
teleprompter I don't know why just I get
you know sometimes you get too into it
you for your lyrics I want I mean I
don't need it now but it would would be
nice just to have this well is it harder
as a musician just because like we're
talking about all these meet all these
rock stars and it's not enough to just
remember the music like you you have to
look like you're having fun like this it
like you have to think about li-listen
and like it's any day above 50 you
having fun like you've made a constant
note that you already made it to 50 so
the [ __ ] that used to bother me like the
news and politics you're already having
fun think about being a musician having
two great albums you break up
remember believes to have that show on
vh1 where are they now
oh behind them you don't know but where
are they now show these guys at number
one albums they're paint houses now and
[ __ ] yeah think about being 58 living in
a small fixed income and getting a call
and saying we're putting the band back
together
what what are you talking about I'm
sitting at home with a grandchild [ __ ]
all that [ __ ] all that his father drink
some whiskey well I can have a few
drinks that's how it starts so well they
always say you know they pay you - they
don't pay you for the shows they pay you
to travel yeah you know just getting out
of the house just I can't imagine being
70 I'd still be relevant in your bag
being 70 and still doing one casino
every month
I mean you paid a hundred dollars to go
see that [ __ ] pervert Bill Cosby down
in San Diego there was four [ __ ]
years ago I knew is a pearl yeah you
know I told you no yeah you told you
told me that's why you wouldn't have to
go anywhere I told you not to go down
there and hang out with the give that
[ __ ] mother hundred hours even before
that I told you but you went to see him
he did in the house you're dealing do
you like two and a half hours even a lot
sitting down 70 and somebody wants to
give me five grand to go do a [ __ ]
show
it was early 2005 all over myself
hmm - and I'd have to depend on Social
Security I could pull off a show it to a
month and get crazy and have a shot at
the keel and pass out a little Joey I
could [ __ ] do that [ __ ] for five or
ten grand you know it's not every week I
don't think it'd do it I saw Rodney in
his 60s and he was having a rough time
already like he was what did he die
Rodney Rodney died in 2004 and see how
old he was
I did that movie with him like in 2001
only backed by midnight so he died in
2004 like October 5th of June 4 yeah Hey
look at his [ __ ] Friday it was his
anniversary and he was it doesn't say
hold on he was born in 71 no he was not
born I went in I went I'm sorry told you
I got deal with got 21 so I made him 79
plus [ __ ] for what 79 plus for 80
[ __ ] rainy today yeah he was 83 I
didn't move it in when he was 81 and it
was a disaster but you got to read the
lines for him you had a yellow eye and
she would come in - ever had to hold the
[ __ ] know you would read the line -
he would go live this chick would say
what the [ __ ] is his fat spec doing in
my chain here we go what the [ __ ] was
fat to make no one in my chair beautiful
Rodney take five and he was gonna sit
down for 10 minutes fall asleep and then
get up he was still smoking weed right
and ain't was still walking around with
a robe on with his nuts out what do you
know all that [ __ ]
I love all that crazy did like was he
making good money for that movie I'm not
sure you understand me it's like a
[ __ ] Lynyrd Skynyrd quad it's like
the it's like the delighted Skynyrd band
the original called you tomorrow and
said you were going on the road with
them dope enough do you really give a
[ __ ] about anything no I was just happy
to be in a Rodney movie I was happy to
walk in a room and to get accepted by
one of my [ __ ] idols when he goes
just with we gave the role away but just
show up tomorrow let's see what's going
on
it was your name gonna be Jojo I'll tell
you what you gonna do and he would put
me in different scenes and then I would
go up my work my Hodja Hodja did you you
know I'm back no I know nobody I know
nobody I was a destroying a Saturday
night and these guys are talking to me
we start talking and they go and the guy
told me who he was and that he was one
of he was casting a [ __ ] rodney movie
and i didn't say two words
that's Rodney Dangerfield that's a
different league economy I'm not that
[ __ ] League and like a week later I
got an audition to go down to sunset
across the street from the church from
that [ __ ] strip club on Sunset by The
Comedy Store just a little casting
office and then I wasn't there Bradley
was in there with the dude and the
casted lady and I just saw Rodney and I
didn't know what to say do you want him
or do you want me cuz I won't you I just
I didn't know what to say and I read the
role as funny as I could he shook my
hand like talk to him for a little while
I walked out and I was like I was good
with that just meeting the guy I was
pretty happy with that
and my agent called me there's listen he
gave the role away but he fell in love
with you just wants you to show up that
they'll come up with something for you
it's great it's crazy that he using an
audition so for eight days in those days
those people used to be real dish oh
yeah oh yeah and you would know it till
you got down to really put a cake in the
game it's like they call you and said
you know like the first time that
happened to me I read for something on a
Thursday and Friday they called me back
from Monday morning at 10th and I host
at the store that night and got [ __ ]
up I didn't like that liquid [ __ ] what's
that liquid [ __ ] you drinking you get
[ __ ] up
GHB GHB and I snorted coke and I ate
some pills when I woke up at 9:00 in the
morning thank God I knew my lines
verbatim and they read you on Western
Boulevard which is a shitty neighborhood
west of the sunset and his shitty
neighbor there's a little building in
there that's what I call backs were
walking on Billy Gardell was there and I
shouldn't Billy's hand what's going on
there was some other guy in there was
three fat [ __ ] hello son Billy went in
when he came out he was [ __ ] pass
and I go Hanukkah only looks great and I
walked into a room and it was Gus Van
Zandt revolta out of Monday morning when
you're hungover and [ __ ] GHB and
[ __ ] coke and God knows what else
Travolta while you were here is this had
it be 2002 2001
huh I was Green as can be and wait what
what year do you move out here in 97 oh
I wasn't ready for this movie but they
were looking for one stand-up comedian
they're like me and Billy so much that
they said why can't he just tour with
two [ __ ] comedians so I walked into
the room I read with Travolta I laughed
at him a little bit and I laughed a Gus
Van Sant it was a Monday and that Monday
night at the store I was there and they
told me Gus Van Zandt was there to see
me I was like God so Gus man saying it
showed the [ __ ] up so I wonder what this
manual it was called the Jimmy Roselli
story
all right it was about a guy in from
Hoboken New Jersey a singer that Sinatra
hated and blackballed and he was way
better than Sinatra because Sinatra
asked them to sing on his mother's
birthday party and he refused so so not
just said you ain't working anyway my
friend the guy wasn't allowed to work
only at strip clubs and with topics so
he would sing a song in between comics
and they wouldn't even Sinatra put the
hammer on him so bad that the guy
couldn't even get out record didn't mean
he was he was yeah he was mobbed up yeah
this time he was just so Jimmy Roselli
would go around Hoboken selling the cars
out of the trunk of his car and people
go Jimmy close the trunk you're
embarrassing us son albums out of the
back of your car so the movie was set we
didn't get an offer yet it was a it was
uh I read maybe one other time I read
for Travolta I read for Gus Van Zandt
then they called me and again and ready
for the producers and then my manager
called me and he goes it's you and God
ow
they just haven't made an official yet
you'll probably hear within the next
week so I went to Miami to do comedy I
was in Miami man
because you're bad news Travolta scratch
the film he's doing that movie about
Scientology battlefield they'll have to
go or whatever [ __ ] it was so I lost
that role - [ __ ] it we didn't lose the
role never even happened
no that's why I mean you said that show
time did that that happens all the time
listen yeah so many people I know in
this time they got a half a million
dollars in the late 90s from a network a
half a million [ __ ] I would take the I
mean a half a million dollars and their
show wouldn't get picked up just to sit
around just to sit around get a show run
and come up with an idea then they
decide they don't want the show what I
did Bronx County they put three million
into the [ __ ] pile they played no no
no no no no they paid the director two
million dollars more is that Bronx
County was a pilot and they were going
to be directed by the guy that directed
he was a P he was a big trend director
and he acted - in fact he played the
doctor and he played the intern of The
Sopranos remember the final year was
Johnny Sack was in the hospital my god I
kept changed in the sheets is [ __ ] that
was a director that was supposed to
direct the Bronx County
it was CBS's answered my PD blue shot a
pilot [ __ ] advertising they told me it
couldn't miss then we got a call one day
it didn't get picked up yeah I always
had hey listen came in there's no
there's no that's yeah that's 84 people
not knowing I I had a deal to make a
wheeler concert movie with Showtime I
signed the [ __ ] deal and they just
called like eight months ago said we
ain't doing it I said watch how the
contract says that I says that says you
are like you know it's like what are you
gonna do you can't make us make it I was
like that's what pissed me so off so
much it's just like then what the [ __ ]
mice what's it what's a contract worth
you know but I know it happens all the
time I'm still up it's just still
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you know I tell people it's so hard to
get all the stars in place to get
something but oh yeah I love when people
say yeah we'll write a scrip it's a
[ __ ] mind [ __ ] it's a minefield
and when somebody gets something done
when you really ask them was it all
worth it they'll tell you that the movie
was great and it was a great experience
but after they all had it up they made
six they made eight thirty to an hour oh
yeah all the work they put in my two
years of Sweat right almost well my
first job when my first album came out
and debuted in the top ten of the
Billboard on the Billboard country
charts I was like old enough to at least
old enough to go you know what let's
enjoy this for a second you know it's an
independent album it's [ __ ] can't be
played on the radio because of the nasty
language as I was finally old enough to
know like to stop complaining for a few
seconds you know because it's so hard
you get those things so few times in
your life you know if ever you know I
mean how I was thinking about you know
every time you fly out of Nashville you
fit even Nashville quite a bit and you
go to that [ __ ] there's like a
[ __ ] in the airport and you know it's
like my all my reminder reminder I go
there and there's a guy playing in a
[ __ ] airport bar at [ __ ] eight in
the morning
and it's just a reminder you know like
I'm on the road weekend's on you know it
just makes me appreciate it you know - I
see this I mean I try you know you try
not to I don't I'm not saying I bet you
can play me but occasion I will [ __ ]
you can blame then I go there's a guy
playing for [ __ ] six bucks and an
airport tootsies and I'm flying out to
LA to do the show you know with [ __ ]
filthy songs you know it's so weird it
did it took me to be married it took me
about nine years and comedy to become
humble yeah
and it's such a big step it's such a big
hurdle to overcome it's such a big
hurdle to overcome to understand that
even if I'm a country musician I don't
compete with you we're allies genome
saying there's no reason to hate I can't
if I look at the top ten I see that you
made it and I didn't I can't be angry at
you yeah well I I'm with you I used to
do that so there's so many parts of the
I would be I would if we used to in the
old days let's say if my album came out
number I didn't have it but if my arm
would come at a number nine I was pissed
at those other eight people but now I'm
just I can actually enjoy it which
I think that's what you're saying just
[ __ ] maturity of just you know the
maturity of an artist is very important
you know because the worst thing you
could do is think about what people
around you were doing Kevin Hart said
something a couple of weeks ago and I
retweeted because he hit it right on the
nose I remember being that person I
could I'm big enough to admit to
everybody in this room that up to 2000
because of who I was surrounding myself
with at the store the certain type of
comic I had around me it's not that I
was complaining it was that I was angry
and frustrated because I felt I wasn't
getting one of the people getting and
that's normal reaction to life if you're
working at [ __ ] Trader Joe's let's
just be honest we work only Trader Joe's
and you in charge of produce you are the
one that checks the lemons and the
pineapples and all that [ __ ] and all of
a sudden there's a job for control of
6:00 in the supermarkets and you're more
highly qualified and you don't get it
you're frustrated I don't care what
individual yeah you'll see it for what
it is you'll throw salt on the matter it
wasn't meant to be but for a day or two
you're frustrated and every once in a
while you'll think about it and you'll
get frustrated at any time you'll
realize that God didn't put in your path
for a reason
if that happens in the comedy that was
happening music oh yeah all the time you
just you got it it's like you got a you
know what I just I just made my new
record you know I'm listening back to it
and I have to just enjoy enjoy the
creation I made and not think about
words they're gonna [ __ ] laying on
the charts is it gonna not sell like my
is he gonna sell more than the last two
you know you just never know but he does
like you say it's being humbles it's
like the is the key to it I think hug
boys the whole thing yeah it's waking up
in the morning not worrying about what
Lee's got hmm I can't worry about what
these guys I can't worry about what
Rogen has I can't worry about what
anybody has I gotta worry about what I
don't have well the other thing too is
there's gonna there's gonna be there's
always gonna be someone bigger than you
no matter what you do
this can't be a competition
it has to be a grooming of allies
helping your allies I was very fortunate
when I got here then I made allies and
you know listen I just got a call from
this [ __ ] restaurant they need
economic on Saturday night it paid 75
bucks I can't do it but I gave me a name
and number you know how many times that
happens just because you're a good
person just because you call people with
gigs Philippe as far as there's a
comment that one last Comic Standing
I can look you in the eye and tell you
four years that guy helped freed me four
years
he always had a room once a week they
owe all those Mexicans had a room
somewhere if they didn't have it they'd
find it like I would call Philippe Ingo
you have anything this week brah I have
nothing give me an hour fool there's a
gig in El Centro that pains 400 apiece
you know and there you are selling land
on your way to San Diego tell central
you know things just work out but you
have to go over that humble that humble
thing and well it's also I've also found
it's hard with nowadays with information
like I could go on my phone right now
and look at charts right now and drive
myself crazy it's all in your hand and
dries you got to stop looking at that
[ __ ]
listen there's a podcast right on iTunes
yeah and for a while I would look at it
and one day I finally realize why am I
looking at that chart it doesn't matter
if I'm number one it doesn't matter from
number 100 what matters is is I'm
consistent and I know that I'm doing the
best podcast I can do everything else
will come later as long as you're
consistent you show up to the dance and
you get out what you have to say that's
the most important thing I don't look at
numbers I never looked at numbers I
don't want to be a part of numbers I
don't want that to be part of who I am
you know what I've got here I'll never
forget somebody come up to me go what
happened you be number 33 of all the
Tino comics
doesn't that bother you and I'm waiting
no that just makes me stronger you know
I don't even think about that they have
like a Latino top comics guy then I was
like buried I was like 34 out of 50 and
people were like you've been in movies
aren't you man at that no really I'm out
here surviving if once you start
worrying about that [ __ ] once you buy
into that [ __ ] that's you go downhill
yeah I know I've seen with my friends
who that hill
the the charts on their phone when
they're [ __ ] driving you know it's
like it hasn't changed in the past
[ __ ] five minutes
you got it you just gotta move all you
just gotta make the best music best
comedy whatever is you can make and then
enjoy the work you know you know it's
fun there
I shot a special for Netflix comes out
the 30th October 30th and I'm not happy
with it why not because I'm not the
person I am now like it was so weird my
head was [ __ ] up
I bought it do me a favor we will open
this [ __ ] door and let Leigh's fly
out before I kill this [ __ ] thing
again because Lee's got like 12 flies
and see a fly and he's been flying
around the last 4 [ __ ] minutes and
he's annoying because you bring these
[ __ ] flies in all the time it's the
hummus man it's the [ __ ] hubba slick
no explain well when you shoot this I'm
here I shot this June 4th and in my
heart I just didn't feel like I just do
think that's are you being too hard on
yourself or no no what do you think I
just wasn't feeling what I'm feeling now
I got too much in my head but it's still
you know like you were talking before
it's all press and something you can't
press right you're doing a certain type
of [ __ ] music right now yeah you're
doing this r-rated country which i think
is [ __ ] brilliant I love it
thanks man what happens it tomorrow you
wake up I start listening to when it's
get it in the morning by 4 o'clock you
look at your girlfriend or you can look
at me and you go you know what this is
what I intentionally went out to do at
the beginning and I'm going away from it
with this raunchy [ __ ] let me get back
to that and also you put out one of
those albums and it doesn't work because
you got away from your original idea
you're not letting it skin it sorry
yeah no I'm your [ __ ] you your we
will walk yeah I know I wish probably oh
yeah yeah before that special something
happened to my head that I wanted to
show the people I could write or
whatever the [ __ ] it was that didn't pan
out
well I'm sure that being Joey Diaz I
became somebody I try to be somebody
saying you did it clean you mean no no
no
I didn't do it clean I just it was
something that did not let me be myself
I don't know what it was no but I
describe it to me like in like
content-wise what was different about it
cuz I had you open for me and you
[ __ ] killed everybody heart wasn't in
it my heart and my head and my soul were
not connected that night when you do
comedy all those things have to be
collected and I think because it was
commercialized or maybe because I choked
I just don't know what it was from the
time I got off the [ __ ] planet just
didn't feel right
the time it's like when I told you the
other day when Conor McGregor would just
sit on the floor thinking about all the
things he did wrong over the last two
years that's what you think of the
moment you get beat up
I remember getting on the plane the next
day and it all coming to me like I was
so disappointed with my performance on
both shows like I was forgetting
material missing beats and missing [ __ ]
that I would do just as a professional I
know to do I missed it I missed the
marks and certain points I just didn't
it was nobody to blame but me but here's
the question for you if this comes out
and people just tell you how [ __ ]
awesome it is
you think it'll change your perception
of the night I don't listen to people
okay you're gonna be exposed to line new
people who are probably gonna love it I
love you know when you suck wila
oh yeah you know yeah when you go up on
stage and this guy missed this chord the
drum is [ __ ] slipping you're slipping
why that you all differently it's
different when I [ __ ] up that's when I
get pissed but when you and then you get
offstage what do people tell you man
that was the best perform it's never
seen in my life and you're like yeah
whatever so you start doubting you like
these [ __ ] Liars you know saying Lee
you're a [ __ ] liar just tell me i
bombed the name the baguette victim we'd
be just as good I don't listen to that
stuff oh my god oh well I think it's
good to not especially nowadays like I
said with the [ __ ] I could if I
wanted to right now I could read a
thousand people telling me that I
[ __ ] suck on
just just not worth listening listen
you're not the thing that makes this
world so special is that we are only
with an ice cream
we are only with the language can you
imagine we all love vanilla ice cream
you know when you put on November rain
it's the first video to hit over 2
million [ __ ] hits it also has 200,000
dislikes go ahead go look at my
guarantee I guaranteed the yeah the
people listen to stairway to heaven go I
know go look at blow up the outside
world by Soundgarden it's got one point
something million hits and a hundred
thousand comes down that thank God not
everybody likes Badmotorfinger yeah not
everybody likes me not everybody likes
you and that's what's great about this
yeah I mean not the goal if I'd if I
made this kind of albums and everyone
liked me that's when I knew I'd be in
trouble yeah yeah the Soundgarden blow
up the odds have rolled that one yeah
has a eight and a half million views for
two forty two thousand likes and one
point one thousand dislikes
one point one thousand people said that
I love eleven hundred people it might
blow up the outside yeah well I mean
look but Badmotorfinger can't make a
better record no but my point is it's
not about records you know it's about
[ __ ] me not gonna like everything I
looked at a Beatles song that was on
there one night and it had like you know
a hundred thousand dislikes it was like
a stupid Beatles song I don't know what
the [ __ ] song was happiness is a warm
gun or whatever the [ __ ] it was that's
right so yeah I think it's a great song
so that's what makes us special that we
all know people people don't forget
people protested the Beatles I always
try to get them banned did you know that
I didn't know that yeah Elvis saw them
you know like you said everyone even
what they're tough at the top they're
always looking down
Elvis saw them as it's because Elvis was
the king he saw them as a threat and
tried to get them banned from America
he's like I know I know a way to stay
that number one don't let him in the
[ __ ] country he tried to get the band
The Beatles didn't know about it till
they they broke up years later but yeah
he was like even at the being at the top
give him what any [ __ ] competition I
read the Zeppelin book the hammer of the
gods
yeah but there's a chapter in there
we're [ __ ] Led Zeppelin wasn't I think
they were playing in Memphis and they
got a call that [ __ ] Elvis want her
safe and they went to Elvis his house
and helvis introduced him to Lisa Marie
and the baby and they [ __ ] they talked
and I think him and Jimmy Page trade
watches they traded watched each home he
was a fan of their so I don't know I
don't know I know he was a faint Led
Zeppelin well honey you know he was I
think he was Frank bear with the Kings
you know yeah but I think this was right
you know it was competition tie was the
first it was the first artist that
actually challenged him at the true on
the charts i think is what what did it
by the way I heard a great Elvis story
which is so I recorded my new record
that's coming out in November at RCA
studio a which is where Dali recorded
Jolin Whelan recorded their Elvis
recorded their I mean all the big boys
is probably the you know one of the
great studios left in America and
someone was telling me a story about how
I'm Elvis had just met Lisa Marie and
she wanted to see him record a song with
the he had it was doing a big ones big
with the orchestra and everything and um
he wouldn't impress her but he'd already
recorded the song so he so he told he
told Doug engineer producer in the band
goes this girl really likes coming in so
let's just pretend let's just because
the producer goes we nailed it yesterday
we don't do it again he goes no no let's
just go play it pretend like we're
playing and we'll just play the track
lip-sync basically and then and you guys
just you just follow my lead and Lisa
Marie comes in and Elvis goes you know
he's lip-syncing a song I recorded the
[ __ ] day before he goes like telling
the bass player
no no play like this and tell him like
the violin player no no like as if he's
running the show
which he wasn't the day they recorded
the producers running the show he's
trying to impress her and leeches
so he recreated the whole [ __ ] in
this studio where I recorded my new
record he recreated the whole song
if they were recording and then to
impress Lisa Marie when you walk into
these studios and they tell you the
history of this there's something happen
to you oh yeah you feel it you feel
you're just like first of all I mean
your first gut instinct is what the [ __ ]
am I doing here
and your second instinct is like there
is like rooms do have like a soul you
know like you can feel you know wailing
in there we will leave that I do I do a
thinks do a route I think studi I don't
think I mean not just regular I don't
think like my parents bedroom does but I
think recording studios
I mean Chet Atkins built this studio for
the Everly Brothers back in the day you
know this is historic studio that the
studio next door to it is a museum and
this is a still a working studio you
know so just to you know just to know
I'm standing where Elvis stood and
singing it just this guy it's gonna
affect your performance no matter what
you no matter what you think you know I
was watching something the guy was
talking about like being in the room
with somebody recorded know what the
[ __ ] it was touching the walls and
feeling the energy and I believe that
with some comedy clubs that you probably
yeah yeah and you could smell the comedy
in the air like you like I'm gonna do
okay tonight that's a--that's a thing
too with these old Studios is they don't
really redo them it's you got it's like
the same floor it's the same walls it's
the same whatever you know it's just
like Whalen really stood here
Elvis sat in this [ __ ] chair or on
this on it walked up these stairs or
whatever it is you know so I think that
history when you walk like whenever I
walk in a place and I look at the walls
and I see who else perform they're like
I don't know what I feel I feel like I
don't want to think about we are
recording recording recording music is
just like a lost art form the act of
knowing where to put the microphone is
only because everything's so [ __ ]
computed lepra knows about these still
computerized and sampled so to get a
good drum sound and know how to Mike it
and [ __ ] like those those good rooms
that were the drums like we're we're
John Bonham sounded so [ __ ] good
those rooms don't exist anymore cuz they
tore him down
to build a [ __ ] Kmart or whatever you
know so when you find a when you get
into a room like that it really you know
you hear the drums the way [ __ ] you
know the you know when you when you're
stay in the room where dolly heard the
playback of Jolene and goes you know
that's the tape it does something to you
I think I was very historic I like Mike
performing at the calm you store knowing
that Richard used to perform on that
[ __ ] yeah that would though I think that
would be the I mean Kasim his mom that
was when I first realized that I realize
especially coming from the jersey up but
I mean especially me you come from
Kentucky if I'd known that I was gonna
you know especially coming from anywhere
yeah coming from anywhere if you're a
female singer from Minneapolis and one
son you're in a stage and they said that
this is the same stage [ __ ] but Donna
did like a virgin it does something to
you coming from anyway you know when you
walk into a room that somebody else was
there that was famous or whatever and
there you are you a jesus [ __ ] christ
maybe I'm a hat for a year you know
that's what you think that yeah halfway
there you like maybe I'm halfway here
you mean that's what I always think
about like when I was standing like I
said where I was staying singing where
Elvis used to saying I was like thinking
about back to when I was playing my my
friend's garage you know and trying to
get a decent [ __ ] record it's like
how the [ __ ] did I get here
just you know the whole journey it all
comes it affects the performance - I
probably fix your performance - just the
Comedy Store yeah I think about like
before I go onstage I get anxiety yeah
but a good anxiety it's a good anxiety
it's the fuel inside of me and sometimes
I'll go snap out of it you know
Richard Pryor was in here or Kennison
was in here and a grandma blow and he
pulled it off you could pull this off
you know I always think of Kenaston when
I go down there and I think is fine I
think the poor Moody when I go down
there and that's what I think of you
know I think of those things before I go
onstage and it calms me down
and then you know I mean I'm doing I'm
not uh the I'm not the obviously a
comedy guru but I watched those old
Richard Pryor and I had to me what that
could have come out today you know the
problem what's going on today is
specials are being shot you read the
Keith Richards book yeah he did the
chapter on live albums yeah why are
people don't make live albums don't walk
because technology took over so much
that we can't make a live album no more
they have forgotten how to wire drums
yeah
well that also bears why make a live
album on their lipstick yeah they don't
know they don't know anything
you know when you watch a Lenny Bruce
special from the 60s watch that special
that camera don't move that camera has
Lenny from three inches above his knee
to two inches above his head and six
inches from every shoulder that's it
well now that had gone Netflix and
there's every [ __ ] there's 800 comedy
special see a guy laugh ain't going back
you don't see the back of the studio
you don't see the long shot it's focused
on Lenny yeah you know somewhere along
the line that feeling went away they
wanted to start getting side shots and
behind you shots and all those shots are
great but to me it takes away at least
from my thing what I do I can't do on
tape I've noticed it that I'm better
live than one on the tape it that's why
he is I would never send my tape
way before any of this [ __ ] happened I
wouldn't send my paper yeah
a lot you saw me at the store live and
you came up to me and said hey I want
you to play my club I wouldn't play your
club if it meant sending
well Dylan still says that he goes the
albums were just blueprints he goes to
only if you want to hear those songs the
only way to they were met they were
meant to be played live they meant they
were not meant to be reported he's like
they were recorded because that's how
that was the best of business and I have
to make records but he's like you want
to hear the song company not now but he
can barely [ __ ] sing anymore but all
his songs he says they were made they
were constructed to be performed it's
crazy how they just got me crazy and
crazy with the special somewhat realms
of the special issue and I've always
believed just to keep so when you're
doing it in that special dick you don't
have no [ __ ] say you could tell them
maybe [ __ ] times they don't give a
[ __ ] but did it don't come to you and
tell you how they got this camera with a
hinge on it I don't want the camera with
the hinge on it
I want one [ __ ] guy with a camera
straight ahead taping six inches up like
I just told you but they don't listen
because everybody wants that shot of the
cigarette in the ashtray it's [ __ ]
avant-garde that's not what I'm about
yeah so four years like in 2004 a trend
started in this town that even the
industry didn't want to come on see
there was a time you call an agent no I
meant wheeler how you doing Joey dis
harity what's going on nothing man gonna
shut the Comedy Store tonight at 10
o'clock I just wanted to invite you to
come see that was great people will at
least come down and tight you call the
next day anything are you a little rough
for me I don't know what I could do with
you then it got to the point where they
would tell you send me a tape let go no
you're the Beverly Hills come watch me I
got to that point like I got the nap
later early 2003 I was like I'm not
sending the old tapes I think in my
whole 27 career 27 year career I think
first thing I sent out to read tapes and
one of them didn't have anything on it I
just wanted to [ __ ] with the guy and he
gave me the job because when you go get
paid in the comedy room you'll see that
the guy that's paying you behind them
there's a thousand tapes with dust on
didn't watch those tapes why did that -
cuz now after the success the first two
records some of the bigger record labels
came along they're like you want to meet
with you so come on down to a show never
[ __ ] yeah no no [ __ ] chump
you know Led Zeppelin got lied to
Atlanta
got signed to Atlantic and they never
saw a land thing Atlantic's never saw
that job I believe and they got if you
read the [ __ ] the man who led zepplin
to Peter Grant book Nia Atlantic sound
signs Aplin without saying them gave him
a huge advance bonus and gave him points
that would never hurt him in the music
industry at that time read that book by
Peter Graham I want the big John man
yeah I mean I mean like I said I was
just saying it I mean after the success
the first two records all these big
labels were coming out and they were
they were they wanted me to meet I'm
like what the [ __ ] am I gonna meet you
for of having success ya know with my
own label of what how much money can you
give me you can't give me there's no
there's no way I make I don't want to
give numbers but you know 90% of my
album sells you can't you're gonna what
are you gonna do get me on the radio you
can't say [ __ ] on the radio it's a waste
of my goddamn time so they would say but
you weren't serious right oh come on
Sierra yeah yeah somebody said they
heard John serious your oh yeah I mean
she's still [ __ ] look I'm still you're
halfway there but nowadays I got bit
even leave with you got serious you got
YouTube you got Spotify they don't need
that I don't need a [ __ ] record label
and that record labels gonna spend a
million dollars on [ __ ] advertising
that I don't want and they're gonna and
then they're my first million dollars
it's [ __ ] gone just do it myself
yeah I don't need those [ __ ] that's
what the beauty about today is yeah that
if you're a real musician and you really
just want to get your musica you get it
you can if it's good you want to be an
online star I know you have a different
plan
that's not your plan but if you love
what you do but if you want to be a star
you got to go with the big label I just
want to make the wave I just want to
make music and make a living like to do
it yeah that's it that's it but if you
to be missing this both ways you go with
a label or you could put your own [ __ ]
out today is what I'm saying it's not
what it was 20 years ago
you know what it was nobody's holding
you back anymore there's no reason to
hold you back your music is that good
[ __ ] get a youtube video and let's go
if it's that good 20 years ago I mean no
you couldn't do [ __ ] you needed the
label you need the label but now you
don't need it so what I think about
I think about what the internet is done
with cobbling and how Comedy Central not
only who watches it because number one
they got wider for 20 years they didn't
give us the best comedians I were out
there they gave us what they thought
they gave us the ones that had to look
don't want that hit the tattoo the one
that had the funny haircut they didn't
give you the problems per pound funny
people straight a lot of credibility
over he is I said here sometimes at
night I'm listening to the cars or
whatever [ __ ] I'm listening to b-52s and
I'm diggin what I'm listening to but I'm
also thinking about how about all the
good bands I never got a chance to
listen to it because a label to design
well what we you and I are more but the
differences to is like you and I we seek
out this stuff most fans just only watch
what MTV play you know what the radio
plays so you and I at least seek out
[ __ ] you know Iggy Pop or whatever it
is a [ __ ] Black Sabbath I have
listened to everything yeah if I don't
like it if I don't play the [ __ ]
videos I don't like it it's like
broccoli I don't like it I'm 55 I really
know I don't like it I don't get him
your marinated with ginger sauce I don't
care if you put [ __ ] juice on it
I don't like [ __ ] broccoli okay and I
write this age I know what I like and
what I don't like and let me tell you
some I've when I was before I was 16 17
I was very partial to music well they
moved to Colorado would I let my mind
wander that was the best thing I ever
did I listened to everything I could
yeah you told me last time that you
didn't really dig the Beatles at first
no growing up you know why I dig the
Beatles I didn't think the Beatles they
were same reason like Bruce Springsteen
too many people like yeah it drove me
crazy I've stopped I've stopped doing
that because my thing is I don't want to
base my decision when I listen to on
other people know whether it's a big
crowd or a small there's a 50% of people
have to assume listening to music their
friends listen to and say it's great
just to fit in yeah 50% of people I saw
growing up I saw a grown up to be cool
you got to be the kind said whatever 50
percent could tell you what the [ __ ]
they don't listen telling what the [ __ ]
they don't wall isn't so they don't give
a [ __ ] whether your feelings get hurt on
that you know jim Florentine sat across
from me
you don't know how many parties we
wanted to me my buddies just took the
[ __ ] jukebox and threw Springsteen out
of there and we don't want to hear
Springsteen in Jersey come I think New
Jersey no other New Jersey we don't get
we don't want no [ __ ] Springs me you
better put Black Sabbath on that
[ __ ] you know Beatle fans always
held the trump card
for years yeah I mean it's different for
me because I was yeah you could up to 79
you couldn't win an argument bro Van
Halen's first down have you heard it
[ __ ] the tremendous eruption Eddie Van
Halen's great but there was always one
[ __ ] there we go ups wait to the
Beatles get back together and he trumped
you you are you're right wait till the
Beatles get back together I'm [ __ ]
when John Lennon got shot people were
jumping up and down the streets because
of the [ __ ] Beatle fans because they
didn't want to hear that nothing but
nine years all they heard was Beatle
fans going yeah Led Zeppelin's good
whoops wait till the Beatles get back
together wait that really what they said
all the time there was just idiots that
were walking around and I like the
Beatles like I liked help that was the
only early [ __ ] I like that's from
revolution on whatever that a revolver
yeah revivals and then with the Indian
or not what the Hindu and they did acid
and they weren't [ __ ] bananas they
all started wearing sandals and playing
that [ __ ] guitar and they said Atari
yeah then they did the [ __ ] album
with the stones for a lot of people
don't know about they did like a cult
album oh [ __ ] Jimmy Page designed that
out oh yeah I don't know that the live
thing you know this is 66 67 in fact you
know gave me the CD Eddie boy 2 for me
yet and he called me one day from amoeba
and he goes what you need anything and I
said see if they got that and he found
it for $9.99 and was jumped out to build
me I don't even know what you're telling
me there's a stole now [ __ ] I can't wake
my buddy up he's an engineer
this is stoner i stalled out one hit is
the name of the song that's 19 [ __ ]
ed 94 94 try the way
the peaceful city type of peaceful city
with a capo rolling stone see what you
get if you look at the one that said
when the Beatles put the one with the P
out that everybody thought Paul
McCartney was dead now you know all
about that Stan they were playing with
white people worse than Conor McGregor
was they were telling people that [ __ ]
Paul McCartney was dead still releasing
albums they walked across the street
barefoot and Abbey Road which meant that
they buried you in a casket barefoot all
of them had shoes on I'll accept Paul
they were doing some [ __ ] wits and
[ __ ] people but that one out what did
it come up with no I could be just a
shot away peace love and tragedy don't
know nothing for the role or your
YouTube I'm on going YouTube okay this
is what about music and now we're gonna
hear this [ __ ] now for now walk around
the peaceful city something like that
Rolling Stones with a capital R has
capital R L me the guard beasts of
burden no no that [ __ ] I'll find them
well and let report back to the
Commission yeah well you know there's a
weird out they have it's the stones
Jimmy Page played on it a couple people
playing on it I think [ __ ] John
Lennon played on it and it's got some
great [ __ ] like two or three great
stone songs and nobody knows about this
out it's ain't made in the shade nobody
knows about made in the shade well their
best times but I never listened oh yeah
I might know it yeah
oh wait the shade there's one of those
thousands that nobody knows about
I thought I had hit it's a great book
it's out that nobody you just stay
slipped it in there now I can't remember
the name of the Sun and so I keep me up
all [ __ ] night
but anyway that's what I think about now
I think about it as a comic that yeah I
got to listen to Lynyrd Skynyrd I got to
listen to Molly Hatchet I got the lizard
so [ __ ] Led Zeppelin did you see
Skynyrd love you no no never saw no no
no no they were about 11 hours and I
could lie to you tell you I had tickets
for guard tonight my friend Steve Villa
oh I would call for this [ __ ] song he
went he had tickets mm-hmm for let's get
in Ted Nugent at the garden right before
they were and they were about to switch
a many never last I was here you played
me Skynyrd open up four stones and they
[ __ ] slaughter them yeah they say
then did you watch the documentary I
thought was great yeah yeah well well
they said they they beat the stones up
and they walked out of the tongue yeah
what they walked on I said that was the
one rule mentally you don't walk out of
the tiger they beat the [ __ ] out of
the stone he's pretty interesting I love
all the I love when you drop by with the
Elvis door you got telling yeah we just
miss out this [ __ ] like that
so you're we're Friday night you're in
Tampa Thursday night Atlanta this
Thursday Friday night
Tampa Saturday West Palm Beach so we're
on the West Palm Beach same night I'm a
West Palm Friday and Saturday okay so
Saturday if I get done early
yeah because we just missed each other
somewhere else also
yeah forget what somebody did not
natural somebody said you talked to
Philly
somewhere the last couple weeks I was in
Philly Boston yeah I was just in Philly
so we were in Philly was it a pit I was
in Pittsburgh I think I can't remember
nowadays I have is do you are even or
them so are you going out just with your
band or just Kid Rock for right there we
do both go to Wikipedia and look up
growing Stones out that's the easiest
way let's find it that's the easiest way
not paying the name of this [ __ ] out
but it's the most obscure out and it's
got two songs in it than a [ __ ]
phenomenal
well your D thing was 66 it's a starbase
credit to the stones
yeah aftermath no give my goddesses out
of our heads [ __ ] computer
now I'm looking up keep going
are these albums the other way all right
keep on to them and that you make
swallow keep going
all right so one hour down talking about
that they all did together keep going
keep going
no satanic Majesty Oh their satanic
Majesties request yes gold is that what
your time I know that's one out keep
going keep going keep going keep going
oh yeah it doesn't even come out as a
Stones out that's how [ __ ] keep going
the other way now cuz the other way it's
some girls it's only rock and roll go
type so some girls crave some girls is
the best they have Beggars Banquet
between the buttons half the man keep
going out of our heads keep going 12:25
that's it yeah yeah no can I give you a
couple underrated stones records
black and blue is really good tremendous
out one of my all-time favorites
emotional rescue under every badness and
you know what else I used to rug to
every [ __ ] day when I got to the
prison was the one that came out with an
81 back to you tattoo that's a great one
too
that's a great [ __ ] out day booze and
all this [ __ ] on lockers I mean the
stones up until like steel wheels they
were [ __ ] great that's like that's
still wheels I didn't like that [ __ ]
steel wheels in this 91 something like
that yeah whenever it's a rock in a hard
place
yeah that's it listen man 30 [ __ ]
years you're gonna have a couple bad
nights Oh exactly I mean you know you're
gonna have a couple bed night auto auto
listen I got I'm not you're not gonna
hear me arguing about the Rolling Stones
you know I mean when you put out 20
great albums what do you got no none
left in the tank that's none left in the
tank and they still listen you know
watching these older guys go out now I
never dreamed when I was a kid this
wasn't happening yeah yeah you had Kenny
Rogers you know with the white hair but
to think that God's arose
you know and they're not even old
they're in their 50s they're not even
though I heard they sound great I didn't
see I saw I listened to the the show
from the forum my neighbours this lads
Slash's godmother she calls him saw oh
yeah and she invited me they had a box
and I was just I think we did a podcast
and when I went home that night I
listened to the last concert from Sirius
what I'd pay if I would have paid 600
for those tickets I would have been
pissed no hockey she was with me because
they didn't work up to me I didn't want
to pay six for all four oh yes - I read
the whole foot ain't no show or 600 ohms
yes slash carried the whole [ __ ]
concert / was [ __ ] phenomenal so I
remember I paid 20 bucks see Nirvana I'm
like is it really worth 20 I mean the
memory of those but old days I paid 15
to see Prince Sheila E and nucleus it's
gonna be tough to get me to lift a rock
for [ __ ] I paid 1550 for Pink Floyd
the war the first night it's gonna be
tired Joey the [ __ ] lift the rock for
three bills it's just tough it just
doesn't equate to me and I'm I'm with
him and it's just I love bands I love
music you know it just doesn't [ __ ]
equate for me so I just there's no name
no show worth 600 [ __ ] bucks I think
you know a couple years ago two years
ago Cat Stevens did or whatever theater
tickets were 300 [ __ ] dollars that
means I take a date as a civilian that
six of those six I'll take a date dinner
all that [ __ ] yeah that's a great it's
better be a hell of a [ __ ] night yeah
so you know I see it but I don't see it
I see the value for the nostalgia you
know these bands are going on on the
weekends these black bands from the 80s
they do like twenty two bands each band
us three songs you know I'm sowing - you
[ __ ] kidding play those tickets in
like 60 bucks everybody makes a [ __ ]
living yeah that's right Doug about Kid
Rock did a tour few years ago where
every seat in the place was $20
and you can you can make a lot of money
if you sell 20,000 tickets to 20 bucks
but it's that listen you go around the
corner here on Lancashire there's a
place a health food place you go in
there you pay $10 for an acai bowl okay
it's a good eyesight Bowl but it's ten
bucks you're not paying for the outside
ball you're pacing with paying for the
guy's rent yeah
somebody told me if you sell out the
garden at like 69 95 tickets you walk
away with a hundred grand it's not a lot
of money when you play the guard you get
you got to pay union dues you got to pay
everybody their fire bill they think
they're doing either thing yeah so like
people think that when you play the
guard you walk away with two million
[ __ ] dollars unless your tickets up
three hundred four hundred dollars then
you may you know Billy Joel does the
residency there but if you're gonna show
it to garden for 60 bucks and sold
without 18,000 people after the house
charges and the Union well I was gonna I
was gonna go see Elton's doing his
farewell tour in Nashville
two tickets 500 it was two tickets 500
bucks I go I'm not to tell them farewell
some other time I'll go home and put on
[ __ ] wit [ __ ] it's a little bit
funny oh it's goodbye yellow brick road
yeah please no I took a hit of acid and
committed to go see Pink Floyd Roger
Waters and I wasn't going a dollar over
200 me and Ari and christen f1 all the
way down there and me and I are you
juiced to the end we looked at each
other we're like we're not paying 300 is
that selling outside yeah that's a true
story me and Ari took a hit of blotter
acid before the baby was born we took
the train right from here and Lancashire
and we went downtown we ended up getting
so high we went to what's the place I
had the roast beef dip that everybody
talks about
well leaps yeah we went into Philippe's
and we ought to fool them with too high
to eat it we just looked at each other
back back better money spent and we win
we took a train back to my house and we
watched some movie on HBO everybody let
that one with tripping our balls off I
just can't see it I just can't see it I
just don't want to see it if you pay one
time you know you go to a sporting
and I'm not thinking about me I'm
thinking about you your wife and your
kid $50 what's the part they go to a
Rams game and you gotta walk a mile
ahead I walk a mile and a half I'm not
paying to get that's it's ridiculous you
know the prices of tickets are insane
across the board for any sporting event
you know I'm not thinking about me I'm
not thinking about Brad Pitt I'm
thinking about the guy that works 60
hours a week discipline yeah that's why
I've spent a lot of time I'm making sure
my ticket prices are down am I on my own
[ __ ] fight with them every my own
shows I can it I don't never go to
Foxwoods again I'll never go to Foxwood
what's I don't know what that is
foxes are cut razor is a theater I just
play the Boston you know why it's a
sixteen dollar surcharge when you buy a
six No yeah that's great I don't see a
dollar of that so you don't make enough
money you're gonna charge sixteen
[ __ ] dollars so that means my tickets
are twenty seven plus sixteen
that's not what I'm about yeah I put my
tickets at a certain price so the
blue-collar guys get caught well I see
these people charged in 35 and 69 that's
great that's great but you're pricing
yourself out I'm with you man always
what I don't need to make that money I
don't need to do it I don't know why I
thought I I thought a year ago was that
when I thought when they they started
charging making my tickets over $15 I go
I'm not worth it it's not worth it yet
and then they just you know but then the
fees come in all sudden oh they kill you
what fees that's not fair to us as the
artists we don't see a dollar of that
fee plus you're selling drinks [ __ ] and
you're selling food and you get money at
the door I get a percentage of it what
the [ __ ] you know when does it end so
you're taking a percentage you're taking
the restaurant and now you're charging
the poor [ __ ] kid sixteen dollars to
download a [ __ ] ticket I can't do
business mutant you know I used to do
for a while so I asked now after the
Foxwoods I asked them what's the service
charge and what's all the [ __ ] if
it's too much I don't want to be you're
gonna give me 50% of it then charge
whatever the [ __ ] you want but if you
don't get me give me a taste of it this
goes in your pocket
I'm not know if they do that for I guess
comedians mergers and it's being a deal
but what they do they take a piece of my
bootys a piece everybody you I you might
start doing I start playing
in places I would go before the show
you'll bring me the man I want talk to
the manager I go here's the deal what do
you take from of my merch they usually
they sometimes think of 10% 20% few
specific and I can I go here's the deal
if I break the bar record tonight I
ain't paying it he shakes my hand and at
the end of the night they count up the
bar and I go you ever made this much
money from alcohol and he goes no it's a
new bar record I go that I'm taking my
money I'm getting the [ __ ] out of here
first of all there's a lot of money in
merch that's another thing I overstep I
don't want to bring much I'm happy that
you paid the 25 just together yeah Kenny
I'm a music you got it
yeah I also want you to come over to me
and shake my hand and tell me you listen
to the podcast tell me that I sucked I
see people that won't walk over because
they're embarrassed because they don't
want to pay $20 for a t-shirt I don't
ever want that to be the feeling in
between these and the people that come
see me I'd rather go out there take a
picture for free and shake and even if
you come up too many time with the
podcast sucks and I suck I'd rather that
and have a t-shirt in front of me number
two it takes away from my focus in
between shows I gotta talk to more
people and sure I don't want to do that
I want to be focused for both shows I
don't worry about an extra large shirt
go looking for a to excel I don't want
to do that that's not what I get my
mother sales when I'm a comic yeah well
I was snorting coke and I was a dirty
fiend I didn't sell nothing I'm not
gonna start selling [ __ ] now I create a
level a playing field that's level I
don't pay for them to absorb nothing out
of my range I don't expect you to either
I know what I'm worth and sometimes I
cut my own throat by not charging a lot
but I know what I'm worth I want you to
be able to come see me instead of you go
on Jesus because I think about it even
when they say $35 I'm thinking 70
[ __ ] dollars that's without drinks
that's without you sushi that's without
the ubers that's without the babysitter
so well I fight album price all the time
to be iTunes sells them for $9.99 I go
it's a [ __ ] file I'll give it make it
$5.99 make it $7.99
you know I got a mother what do we got
him on palos two dollars yeah I've
always believed that the Hartford comes
first and the money comes second
once you put that order that's where it
all goes down ship and that's what these
ages try to do to you they want you to
put the money before the heart I make
three times more money if I play cops
and I play the punch line where do I
play Lea punch line I'm not gonna give
you a good show at cops yeah I know it's
none of your business the difference but
it's substantial and I refuse to do it
because the first thing on my list
because unlike most want you give a [ __ ]
that's 55 no I was giving a [ __ ] too
much and now I don't give a [ __ ] on
stage but I still give a [ __ ] about the
family we've created yeah I mean wants
to insult anybody when I come to your
restaurant I'll pay whatever you want me
to pay it but I'm the right I'm stupid
like there's a place in Hollywood that
they saw hot dogs
I'm a fat [ __ ] this is 20 years ago I
love hot dogs I'm gonna be taking my
wife there one day on a date and she
said to me I know how good was that
[ __ ] hot dog she was it was pretty
good but two hot dogs on lemonade and
fries 28 dollars and I didn't even dawn
on me I was like holy [ __ ] I was 14 a
piece for a hot dog fries and a like I
used to be a downer I am I'm never going
there again and I never went back in
there even though they did have the best
[ __ ] chili you know this isn't Holly
I don't even think that's still there
huh they had this bavarian beer chili at
their put those raw onions you dick
would just squirt when you burn it so
there's you've been for the hotdog you
dig we just go and you feel that's hot
to me that's where tall that's for him
don't let me tell you something the
lemonade was handmade it wasn't that
[ __ ] Minute Maid [ __ ] well any hot
dog that makes me jizz my pants I'll
paint [ __ ] 30h fries with waffle
fries and they give it to you what
alioli mustard like this red [ __ ] Lee
you have no idea
it was the whole of the fat [ __ ] and I
avoided it because it was fourth
now as for us there's a place to see it
hey you just woke up Alina this sorry
we're doing another bond after this
there's a place in Seaside Park New
Jersey I used to go there down the block
from my brother's house they gave you
ten Sabourin hot dogs loaded for $20
lead you know I would go that's the
first thing I do and you're diving it
tends to tell what do you do to attend
our dogs yes you bring them back I look
at them I investigate what tell them
what do you think I do we walk up you
eat ten ten are not right there standing
there two at a time in front of that guy
with two cans of coke 24 bucks and a $10
tip because the [ __ ] chili was
tremendous today you can 10 hot dogs
[ __ ] I'll take that's gonna
Chinese guy and I'll take it yeah we got
it
I want to see for vacations I wanna see
you I'm gonna tell you something I can't
run anymore but I could go you give me
two hundred three hundred milligrams of
edibles and I starve for three or four
hours I have a hot dog I have a [ __ ]
hot dog eating contest I'll eat that
[ __ ] that Chinese [ __ ] and I won't
dump the bread the [ __ ] water
I [ __ ] that's one thing I could [ __ ]
up some hot dogs Jack when I was a kid
that's how I built my immune system when
I came from Cuba I believe the more hot
dogs you ate the more American you were
so I would eat hot dogs every [ __ ]
opportunity I get in those days they
weren't Arab some hot dogs or regular
white people a little dirty with dirty
fingers no gloves you could see when
they get your hot dog out of the water
the oil would slip from their fingers I
didn't give a [ __ ] that's who I am today
that's why my life is 55 there's a
little dirty water dogs Jersey made with
that Hudson River water you can still
see like a little chicken bones float
they said the water from the river yeah
[ __ ] yeah well you think the tap waters
from way that comes from the glaciers
and Buffalo
that's tap water and [ __ ] Jersey City
I closed it darling you put water on at
night leaving your bathtub you walk in
the middle of that you have to turn the
light on [ __ ] be from the light that
comes from the [ __ ] water only think
people are in New Jersey got cancer from
the water I'm in the beam in Coney
Island there's a little kid Doug talked
about traumatized like if you take if
you all go home tonight and you get a
notebook and write about the things that
really traumatized you like to be really
honest with you think about that what
would like that lady that said that
Kavanaugh
miss dick and I rent right away you got
to tell me what was the dick what was it
they have a spot I don't know whatever
really is showing you a man's dick
really that traumatizing I mean I saw a
guy jerking off one time in the park it
didn't affect me at all like why are you
about jerking off in the park one day me
and my buddies threw rocks out of his
[ __ ] we went we played Portland about a
month ago and the dude jacked off
outside of the show no he didn't
yeah he jacked out and I didn't see him
the band rest of the band saw it I said
man I said I tweeted out I said if he's
in jail man I'll bail him out I go my
shows good enough for him to jack off
all if you want to jack off after my
show just don't do in front of me but if
you wanna do it outside I'm down like I
don't like jacking off outside would see
that I don't like jerk on the hot side
either but sometimes I'm not saying I
don't know saying I was excited I was
just saying it's like it made me feel
good good that I played a good show
we'll get the [ __ ] out of here we will
walk I love you to death seeing you I'll
be back here and I'm sorry I couldn't do
the two of you that I was already
confirmed but I can't cancel porn again
they would [ __ ] kill me no I will do
another one will do another we got big
things I'm linking it I'll make I'm
gonna think I'm gonna make an annual
thing we'll do it every year
well [ __ ] your [ __ ] [ __ ] figure
something how much fun we haven't done
shows leaves great dog [ __ ] when I
told when I asked [ __ ] Oh at the know
both either if he brought his harmonica
the poor guy oh god yeah oh my god he
was no I forgot it awesome he ripped it
out he started playing it yeah I got it
I got a no ron jeremy rule now on my
show no you gotta have but you know he
stinks too bad does he really his body
odor what do you think like he smells
good I don't I don't smell people I
avoid smelling I look at Liaquat eyes
got body odor no I don't I what do you
think the Flies follow you they follow
you never have flies for the [ __ ]
team I don't smell like one there's some
bling to it something tell me that you
did not small you're [ __ ] probably
said this bug you- fourth wall it's not
like [ __ ] and doofy tell you right
now leap smells bird and ron jeremy I
can promise you think you smell ron
jeremy oh I've still señal have you had
wearing pool I mean he's
you didn't wasn't Wang it was just like
was it old man it was it was all it was
like old [ __ ] yeah it's like 70 like
[ __ ] from the 70s oh that's terrible
yeah that's you start showing on my gigs
and actually said said this I was
talking to kill you had a bunch of
people too noble to you had Greg Garcia
from My Name Is Earl he went to see a
bunch of people with the yeah it was a
good talking people reached out to me
the next day they're like were you
[ __ ] surprises we didn't know you
were gonna be there right what a great
guy see if [ __ ] told me he was there
nearly [ __ ] he stopped backstage too
by the way so if you're listening come
to the show
back at the Novo I don't I wish I knew
the date but it's end of November just
come come check it out
yeah no way listen whenever this
[ __ ] in town you should be
going in terms a in hello
he's family with the [ __ ] church and
he's earned his [ __ ] right free and
pre-order my new record his new record
well how can they pre-order it dawg
iTunes or any of those places
okay pretty long does it get released
what's a good really called ww3 and what
is the release date I think November
30th okay so you got some time though
the day before is the day or now either
29th is yes I'll be record really really
sure so I'm playing la 29th yeah what
night is that uh Thursday there I'm out
of [ __ ] here at town that's a bummer
well if you're in town I would have made
you go you know what bag tweet it not
tweeted out Fiat and we'll figure it out
I love you we will walk and Safari about
that rolling that roller that Rolling
Stone thing that you thought was me on
the cover yeah you know who did that who
our buddy Mikey
yeah Mikey clad did the him that bad
[ __ ] yeah that tricked me I was
so happy for you I called you
he's on the cover no and I missed the
call and then I see on the podcast
talking about how I was too big for you
yeah I'm like I'm like I didn't miss
your car I think of a [ __ ] then call
me back you should have been if you get
a rolling stolen the first call you are
off your mother well I didn't wasn't on
wrong since I'll come around here and
talk [ __ ] about you these are rolling
stone yeah suck his dick or you [ __ ] him
no but I think I was I think I was on
tour and I did but coming home with your
hand trimmer you [ __ ] [ __ ] that
was that was [ __ ] a Photoshop that
was tremendous
yeah you had me I Love You Man thanks
again I was before the release date
November 30th
and his show in LA at the noble theater
on the 29th and where can they find all
your [ __ ] stuff just look at my
website we own Walker jr. calm that's it
it's that's it all right I want to thank
we will walk again for stop in but most
importantly I want to thank you
[ __ ] don't forget this weekend
Friday and Saturday West Palm Beach
improv 7:30 and 9:30 9:30 Saturday sold
out you got options
you understand me got options I'd rather
you come early and you go home early
well you do what the [ __ ] you want to do
but anyway and two weeks from now on the
25th I'm at elaborate ease in Cleveland
with my man George [ __ ] Perez I
got Thursday two shows Friday and to
show sadly I'll see you [ __ ]
dad can't wait to get a pastrami
sandwich but anyway forget the pastrami
sandwich for a minute the show is
brought to you by my bookie let me talk
to you about my book here right watching
football is fun but like I told you in
the beginning of the podcast it's a lot
more fun when you bet on the goddamn
games guys you've heard me talk about
this for weeks and some buddies are
still on the sidelines whether you're an
exit expert or rookie you should be
better than my bookie why Joey why
should I go to my bookie if you're the
kind of guy that likes to bet a little
bit and win a lot like playing the
numbers on a roulette you can create a
big parlay you pick three teams to win
and if you hit all three teams you could
turn a hundred dollars into six hundred
dollars listen a hundred dollars into
six hundred hours where you gonna get
that type action that there's so much to
bet on you got playoff baseball you got
hockey you got fights you got football
you're gonna college football what the
[ __ ] you're missing out the boat you
want to have a good Christmas with your
family and [ __ ] spread money and be
Johnny Goomba you got to go to my bookie
all right my bookie is the one bet I
know you'll be happy with all year I
recommend these guys you know why I
trust them they've been in business for
years and they grow I've got great
online reviews and their mobile site is
easy to use so cut the [ __ ] it's
time to make some [ __ ] Jesus log on
to my bookie right now and double your
money double your money use promo code
Church CH you are ch4 you dumb [ __ ] out
there and you'll get your first
positive matched a hundred percent so if
you deposit two hundred you got four
hundred to gamble with or to play with
who's better than uncle Joey nobody use
promo code Church my bookie you play you
win you get paid that's how we [ __ ]
do it
number two you ever look at yourself you
look at yourself in the mirror and you
know you know what my mother is white my
father's wife I look a little shiny and
someday you don't need this no more
that's why you go to 23andme it's a DNA
testing service that can offer insight
in the ancestry health wellness and
traits the 23andme health and ancestry
service includes reports and how your
DNA can influence things like your
weight sleep quality caffeine and take
sense of taste and whether you're likely
to be in LOC toast I'm intolerant like
it told me I was and it's easy to do you
just spit in the tube and providing your
23andme kit and mail your saliva sample
back to the lab to be analyzed it's that
simple the minute a support versus the
sweet salty reports you know the sleep
reports the saturated fat and weight
report they tell you all this based on
your genetics and how your weight might
be affected by saturated fats in your
diet they offer tips on which foods to
watch out for if you're trying to eat
less saturated fat 23andme
does it all the lactose intolerant
report sheds insights into how your
genetics may affect how you digest dairy
products how you gonna get this action
somewhere else do me a favor
order your 23andme health and ancestry
kids today at 23andme comm slash Church
again that's 23andme comm slash shirts
CH you are CH that's the number 23 and
me dot-com slash Church 23andme the real
DNA testing service that could offer
insights into ancestry health and
wellness
give it a shot I'm gonna thank 23andme I
want to thank my bookie I want to thank
my people over at uh bookie no I just
said [ __ ] my buddy I want to thank my
people over there at roots a fight they
always send me t-shirts is [ __ ] your
products are tremendous I
roots of fight products and that's it I
want to thank my man [ __ ] wheeler
Walker I want to thank the [ __ ]
[ __ ] but most importantly I
want to thank the church family for
being bad [ __ ]
have a great week stay black see you
Thursday morning nice and early